[Music]
so
open to anyone
all around the world oh my god the
chess.com global championship offers the
dream of playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars know that is not a
typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous
we began with thousands of players
now only dozens remain
he's gonna make it through to the next
phase he secured himself a big place in
the knockouts
the cgc knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends
it's the cgc round of 64.
who will take the next step to toronto
welcome to
the chess.com global championship it is
finally here i'm grand master robert
hess alongside me my good friend
international master lawrence trent
lawrence
it's arrived
yeah we're here finally it's uh time for
the
wonderful
last
64.
what is that actually that's not even
the it's not the quarters it's not the
last a goodness me does it even have a
name whatever it is 64 fantastic players
about to duke it out
for
well one of the most
incredible prizes um ever given in
um online chess we're gonna dig deep
into that
but uh first i think it's appropriate
for for us to give you all
an overview of the format
robert how uh how are things shaping up
in this well let's call it first round
of the last 64.
yeah it is the opening round here
starting today you will watch the first
few matches it is a single elimination
knockout so lawrence you lose you're
gone you have no second chance no other
life and with a time control of 15
minutes plus a two second increment
there will be less moral degradation
than we're used to
yeah um
well i don't know about that let's see
uh but certainly 15 plus two is actually
a very interesting time control normally
with the slightly longer blitz games the
10 minute blitz games is or 15 you get a
10 second increment but with just two
seconds there's actually a chance that
people still flag so time trouble is
going to be a real thing
it certainly will be and the field
includes 64 players in eight groups 32
players had to qualify their way into
the field the other 32 were invitees
based on their rating their uh
luminaries of the game such as vladimir
krumnic so as you see the top seeds in
front of you we also have five world
chess champions including none other
than vishwanathan anand and vladimir
krumnick as well as vessel and tapalov
so it's going to be a great field
lawrence
yeah some superstars of the game are are
going to be playing
um we've got uh current uh
elite players former elite players
upcoming youngsters
it's really a beautiful mix of
uh effective well i would say really
the lion's share of the top players in
the chess world there are some notable
exceptions
however it's a good crowd i can tell you
that
it certainly is and we see the bracket
on the screen in front of us there's so
many exciting matchups that it's easy to
lose track and if we look towards the
middle left of the bracket two of my
favorite matches lawrence we were
talking before the show we have vidit
against serrano and also i love that
match of ray robson against vasil
evancho
yeah you know we've got uh you know
these are two highlights as you said we
were discussing them uh before the show
uh there are a lot of close matches in
this first round i do expect a lot of
upsets along the way it's going to be
really interesting for me robert to see
how the older pros and the older legends
do
in an online format like this
with a slightly unusual time control
there are some of the
let's call them older legends let's call
them 40 plus players who have got a bit
more experience but for example talking
of vaselia vancouver one of the biggest
geniuses chess has ever seen
i can't actually recall him ever playing
a 15 plus two minute game in a in a big
tournament like this so it's going to be
really curious to see how uh they all do
yeah and yvonne chuck has been playing
in title tuesday's more online chess for
him of course he's been the champions
chess tour as well so maybe he just got
his feet wet he's ready to win the grand
prize because the global championship
has a very healthy prize fund first
place being 200 000 lawrence the biggest
first place prize of the year
well when i
first uh heard about the global chess
championship and of course was asked to
do some commentary when they put that
graphic on the screen i asked if there
was a typo this was in the preliminary
stages but no
thanks to the gratitude of chess.com
sponsors and alike uh we have managed to
put together a tournament with what
looks like the biggest prize fund
in chess history i think it's a
reflection also of just how
popular the game is now how many people
are coming to play chess and watch chess
200 000
is
a huge amount of money and uh it's also
a hundred thousand per second and the
other prizes are not to be sniffed at
either so
tons to fight for uh tons of pride on
the line as well in in the first of what
i hope is many editions of this
fantastic tournament
for sure because every single round at
the start gives you five thousand extra
dollars but let's look no further than
this side of the bracket we are starting
in group g
also known as dingley ren's group as the
top seed there and we're gonna have his
match against min one of the most
popular chess streamers one of his whole
content creators out there will also get
former world champion vladimir prominent
you have to pronounce
from armenia it did so well in the
recently concluded olympiad and last but
certainly not least for today at least
in the early matches lawrence nihal
saarin and ralph momento
yeah a nice mix of of matches uh today
you know just talking about that last
match siren against mahmoud um
sarin one of the
most uh
uh impressive young uh uh players to
uh really shine in in the past few years
he belongs to a group
of
absolute superstars who have just
uh taken the really the chess world's
uh breath away by such a rise in the
standings you think of sarin pragnanda
abdul satorov ghoukesh they all belong
to this very special group
and he's playing against ralph mahmedov
who might not be such a familiar name to
some of these players but i can tell you
ralph who's probably just a few years
younger than me
was one of the og's online i mean ralph
mahmedoff
used to play on the internet chess club
years and years ago he's been around for
a long time now tons of experience
very very creative play and
stylistically
i think this is a particularly very
interesting match up where
um you know i don't think even though on
paper
sarin is
you know the favorite now i would say
uh mamedov has got a few tricks up his
sleeve so i would not rule out rav my
medal whatsoever so that's going to be
extremely interesting
kramnik mel kumian
is also kind of interesting because i
feel like they're closer stylistically
they're both very solid players they've
got huge chess culture uh melchumian of
course from the armenian soviet school
and what vladimir kramnik doesn't need
an introduction
so they they both have got a lot of
chess culture and that's going to be a a
very interesting one and what's going to
be really interesting of course is to
see what kind of vladimir kramnik turns
up today he retired from competitive
classical chess uh what was it about two
years ago now uh robert maybe something
like this hasn't played a classical game
has played a few exhibition games a few
rapid tournaments
uh
the the the the kramnik
towards the end of his classical career
was certainly a more boisterous kramnik
actually more reminiscent of the crown
we saw in the 90s
um
so be interesting to see what kind of
mood he turns up in
and very quickly the last match well
featuring the number one seed of this
group dingle
uh no introduction required he will be
playing for the world championship title
against january against as you said the
fans favorite minli
fantastic player uh has got more online
experience i guess then well arguably
he's got the most in not just in this
group but you could compare him to
anybody else in the entire tournament i
mean the guy lives to play online um
this will give him some
advantage but the question is
is it enough to beat somebody as good as
ding
not sure
yeah i love the breakdown there lawrence
it really gave the fans a lot to dig
into and your point a bit about ralph
momento in particular is well taken that
some of the newer fans who came to the
game in the pandemic or just haven't
followed over the board chest much they
won't know just how strong uh ralph
mohammed is so he is going to be a tough
task for neal sarin to handle but what
else is going to be a tough task is the
fantasy bracket i know many of you have
filled those out there are over 10 000
submissions it says nearly but since
that graphic was made more than 10 000
total have been submitted and the top 20
finishers win chess.com merch and
membership prizes so check out your
results all fantasy
formats are fun and if you like march
madness well it's uh september but the
madness starts right now here on
chess.com
yeah do make sure you fill out that
bracket um it's good fun
and you never know
you could get that lucky one time a
hundred thousand dollars for you if you
guessed the correct bracket and all of
the other prizes as well
um you you you know it it it's uh it
would be a nice a nice little gift but
it's certainly a lot of fun just
participating can we
discuss very quickly our bracket
selections today robert because we've
both filled it out who have we got
ding against min oh well let's start
actually with kramnik against melakumian
who have you got here uh robert
you know we were talking before the show
lawrence and most people would probably
be surprised to hear this i am going
with kremnick because it's a four game
match a 15 plus two second increment but
i said to you that ron malcumian could
definitely beat krumnik in this match so
don't be surprised if that happens even
though i don't think it will
yeah i
also agree with you i'm just double
checking i do have kramnik entered um i
think kramnik
uh is just a little bit too strong for
france i mean just objectively speaking
he's been playing a bit online so he's
not completely
let's say cold when it comes to online
formats
uh and as i said stylistically i don't
think this is a great matchup for france
would not surprise me however if frank
did win if he has a really good day
uh he could do it but i'm gonna go with
uh with kramnik on this one
what about the next match
yeah let's discuss i mean sorry lawrence
to cut you off there i was just gonna
say the next match is i mean
there's a thing about these everyone is
capable of beating their opponent
because in a field where the eighth seed
in a group is min and he just became a
grandmaster he's about 25 50 and
classical and even stronger relative to
his classical is his rapid and blitz
play he could actually beat dingley rent
like i again would not be surprised if
that happens
no uh he's just uh a very informed
online player
um i would be slightly surprised though
because it's not as if ding again has
been not exposed to this kind of online
format also it's not blitz it's 15
minutes so you would tend to think that
that probably favors the objectively
stronger player
that being said
anything can happen and
as
uh minly is easily good enough to have a
great day
and find a way to win and in fact looks
as though we've got liftoff
we do have liftoff it is exciting we
have the game between
li ren and min on screen in front of you
right now and
if we just go back just a couple moves
just to see how we got here it was a
sicilian and knight f6 the mamidjarov
variation played by min his knight goes
in the center but then so does dingley
wren so
lawrence it's preparation by both sides
thus far dingley run actually played a
classical game of chess earlier because
he's playing in the chinese league so
good stuff from yeah from both already
yeah um
seems as though this is some kind of
theory but wow we
look at this move here robert
b
four
by d i mean i'll be honest with you i'm
incredibly surprised firstly to see one
e4 on the board ding loren is mostly a
d4 player
so he may have specifically
uh prepared for ming and then to go for
this
b4 move
uh is
wow i mean it is in the spirit of the
position
that's for sure
uh nevertheless
um
it's it's it's kind of shocking so i
guess
it has to be some kind of home
preparation
yeah this whole position looks weird
right there's this pawn on before you're
pointing out that was a sacrifice that
min said i want no part of that but as
we see the position unfolds here this is
pawn on e6 with the pawn already
thrusted to f5 that could be a long-term
weakness but min is claiming important
space on this board right there's a
knight here on d4 okay night before i
can't predict any move lawrence
yeah it's a complete mess already and
i'm trying to work out who this actually
uh sort of benefits really um
not completely clear to me uh
you know does ding really want a dog
fight i i'm kind of surprised at this
approach that being said
if i could take
uh
a side here i would take white maybe
that's just because i'm used to playing
these slightly off beats sicilian or
playing against these kind of sicilians
uh
knight b5 challenging the knight on d4
um you know black has got a lot of
options here it's it's not at all clear
to me
what the correct move is i'm i'm not
even sure that
you know if i played
a move like night eight to c6
is is that is that a ridiculous move
just giving up the bishop in order to
maintain a bit of control i i simply
don't know it's a it's a tricky position
to play actually if you've not looked at
this because
there are no forcing really clear
forcing variations so i don't know who
would you take here robert
well i'm i would say dingley wren just
because he's digly wren i honestly think
that sometimes i look at a position like
this i see the eval bar off the side of
the screen with an advantage for white
but it's not just the fact that it's
dingley red as by the way min played
your suggestion lawrence just developing
his pieces now white has the pair of
bishops the bishop can come to b2 at
some moment to operate on this long
diagonal white castles and there's this
target on e6 it's a backward pawn so i
really like the contours of the position
for ding
yeah and he does castle and you're right
two bishops in an open position like
this the back would pawn on e6 the
bishop's gonna plant itself on b2
uh you would think
at some point maybe there's even some
maybe there is some idea here of just
playing c3
i know it looks slightly strange kicking
that knight and if there's a trade you
have to be careful of some knight e5
jumps but at some moment you might just
want to uh blow open the position with
some central thrust as well so there are
a bunch of ideas here for white um
rookie one is a fairly standard move i
would say in this position just
developing the the rope to a decent
square bishop b2 or d3 all come to mind
um and it looks as though bishop b2 was
played
by d putting the bishop on
a very sensible long diagonal
um so i'm really curious how how ding
works these two bishops in this game and
what is min lee going to do here to
stabilize i feel as though you have to
stabilize it
you know do you want to try and get in
e5 at the right moment king h8 e5 just
to stabilize this knight
what do you think robert how do we yeah
sorry that looks like a viable option
for sure i was already thinking do i
want my king on this diagonal with the
bishop but sometimes we make there's a
quiet move like putting our king in the
corner and it's just a bit slow because
rookie one can happen fast and maybe
there will be a capture on c5 we can't
forget about this tension between the
pawns over here so uh i think that min
is doing quite well he has plenty of
time to work with but i do think that
his position is harder to play lauren so
that's why i'm concerned about his
position somewhat
yeah it's a sort of position which can
go
downhill very very fast as black it
looks as though the moment you're kind
of stable
but
uh a few inaccurate moves the white
bishops come alive and suddenly you're
in big trouble
so
and there you go so min effectively
answering the
the question which was
he doesn't believe he can just sit still
and play normal developing moves because
white's initiative is too big so he's
actually taking the game to
ding and this
move b5
is extremely committal
i
i don't know if i love it
but
fair play
at least he's trying something so what's
the idea here
if for example
it gets very complicated now um bishop
a2 is the the standard move here just
dropping the bishop back
but there is an intermediate move b
takes c5 that has to be considered
because now the knight is is much looser
on d4
um right
you know i think lawrence that this pawn
on b5 i mean it might even just fall
victim right away like what if i just
take on d4 and remove the guard of this
b5 pawn the eval bar shot up to 2.7 so
it makes it clear that something is
hanging here and min's move while it was
adventurous maybe it's an adventure he
wishes he didn't take
so
you're saying knight takes d4 and
and yeah and and ding plays the the the
human move here
somehow it feels like feels like the
move
i think a lot of players would play
because you want to keep that bishop on
the long diagonal and not allow too many
trades
so i still believe white keeps an
advantage here um
and
min
has to think okay
i think originally he might have thought
about playing a move like pawn to c4
but
you just can't keep the bishops locked
out because white will always have the
move d3 at the right moment
um and the bishop
it just slices across the position
precisely
so i'm not sure what min is actually
supposed to do right now if mim plays a
move like bishop b7
just uh
you know white can win a pawn there but
i don't think
ding will do that bishop b7 then you
could take on c5 you could take on d4
and take on e6
but i just don't
i just don't think ding would do that i
think he actually wants much more from
the position something like king h8 does
not look at all clear to me actually
white's pieces are not that great
so yeah you've got and now black has got
a gorgeous bishop on b7 and
this could actually go wrong pretty
quickly so
i don't expect this
uh
to happen
um
so
no move yet from men but i mean you make
a very good point there lawrence i just
have to state that clearly that it would
seem like bishop b7 is a blunder because
losing material with check by the way is
something that most people would run
away from but i like your calculation
that you continue there saying i'm
giving away material but with that
bishop on b7 it is just such a powerful
piece and it gives black
maybe not just sufficient compensation
but a chance to play for more so bishop
b7 is an option though i could see a
simple rookie one slide causing black
some continuous issues
yeah
i'm in uh eating up a fair amount of
time here and and understandably and he
goes to cb4
which um
won't uh disturb ding too much ding has
actually got a decision here
uh or does he because does the move
knight takes d4 run into some b takes a3
but then
how does that work some intimate so yeah
he just takes back this is clearly the
uh the professional move in this
position
and now i
you say the knight can't capture on b4
because the d4 knight is loose and you
don't want to take on f3 because then
the queen for white gets out and once
the queen gets in the game both bishops
are too powerful to deal with
yeah so he goes bishop b7
this makes
sense
so now what for white
is the question do we go rookie one
that's a
fairly straightforward move
um
does trading knight takes d4 in this
position
also makes sense the answer is yes
but what is the follow-up after knight
takes d4964 not clear to me at all
um
so still some
things for ding to resolve here
i don't think ding is gonna
the car honked on the truth you know
trying to figure out what the
exact way to pounce on the e6 pawn but
lawrence you've been correct this whole
game and i have to give you that credit
because
with after b5 retreating the bishop to
a2 anytime you could take this pawn on
e6 i think dingley wren is proving that
the threat is stronger than the
execution let's continue piling up
pressure on this pawn and there is no
way that men can defend it you look at
the eval it's up over plus two so ding
is doing everything correct here and he
will be able to capitalize and gain
extra material at any moment
yeah i wonder if there's
some other idea i mean i'm curiou let's
just say black plays
ah okay i see another issue with black's
position here which is that
in some positions if he plays a very
natural move like rook a to e8 which
looks like the most natural move on the
board here just protecting uh that that
pawn on e6
then at some moment the a7 pawn
might be weak
i'm not sure there's a way to take
advantage of that just here
but
it's certainly in the in the pipeline
and if you don't do that where is the
where is the clean
route again you can win a pawn
but i don't think ding wants to do ah
but maybe this time it's actually two
pawns sorry because there you can
actually take twice on d4
i know you cannot take on e6 robert can
we show that at all
let's
analyze that
so you're saying whatever
yeah so i was analyzing knight 64 knight
64.
bishop tate uh bishop takes d4 queen
takes d4
but bishop takes e6 is a huge blunder
because then rook takes e6 exists rook
takes e6 queen d5 double attack
and
uh
you lose
as white actually there's no way to
protect the rook and made
so
it is one move queen f3 which somehow
saves the day
but
to to be able to spot that in advance
would have been uh something special
because the point is that the queen
takes rook for free the bishop is loose
down on b7 so that would have luckily
saved the day for white
yeah i did miss that one and if that
does save the day then this is this is
actually a valid variation after okay
the reason i say that is because if we
go
back to uh after rookie one rookie e8
uh and then uh ah he yeah he did did he
take on f3 in the game did he might have
yeah he took another three
okay this move i'm very happy to see is
wide it feels like it gives me a fair
amount of breathing room
and the bishops are now working unabated
along the long diagonals for example
what's what's now a nice
uh a nice stabilizer of a move
well d2 at some point is loose b4 is
also loose at some moment but i don't
think that black can take either one as
the e6 pawn and more will fall and
so bishop c3 just a calm move like that
not another question
bishop b3 as well just opening up this
rook on ea file so
i like how you frame it though
stabilizing moves because look what ding
does he does a rook lift and that
actually made his advantage go down a
teeny bit so
i get his style i get why he's making a
move like this but maybe it gives men
some chances
yeah but i still think this is a good
move and very very difficult for men
because now um
you are preparing a doubling of the
rook
on uh on the e file adding huge pressure
to e6 and also as you said it's a rook
lift this rook is very versatile on the
third rank can go to g3 can go to d3 can
go to c3 can go to a3 i mean pretty much
every square has got some utility
and uh so i actually really like this
move and very important of course in
this position is that the bishop on b7
is not protected so black does not have
a night jump here to disturb white or at
least a night jump which is
um
particularly worrisome
and in fact there are not some some
night jumps that lose for example the
move knight a5 here if you were trying
to put the knight on c4 let's say might
just run into queen g3
and that might just be the end of the
game because you're threatening mate
uh and then the knight is hanging so min
plays king h8 but that doesn't actually
now queen h5 is just a move i would be
uh
busting to play in this position
basically with the idea that oh well
i've i am blundering stuff or am i it
gets very complicated so for example
queen h5 with the idea of rook to h3
just threatening
um
to to crash down but here this is where
maybe e5 might be able to be played rook
h3 and then finally you can go h6 and i
don't have my queens h6 traps because uh
the diagonal is closed so
you have to be a bit more precise here
as white so rook 81 this is by far
um as my good friend julian hodgson
former british champion one of the
greatest attacking players of all time
taught me you've got to bring all your
toys to the party
don't leave a rook on a1 put it on e1
and now literally every single one one
of white's pieces is involved in this
attack
and pressure on the black position
and
if e5 is played
by mainly
which it just was
the question now is
does ding
want to take on e5 here and take on b7
the answer probably is he i think he
would prefer not to
is he going to play a little move like
it's a difficult it's a diff it's
getting now it's getting now a little
bit messy actually
yeah it's definitely a position where
min is starting to feel better um and
well we'll
we'll come back this for sure we haven't
checked out the other two games so maybe
we should hop on around lawrence and all
right this game
kramnik game is looking spicy so
let's go on over there because i just
saw
these knights these menacing knights on
f4 and g5 along with this queen on g4
this king on g8 isn't going to survive
harambe kumian says queen c2 gets the
job done
love this move by han melekumian this is
a classy little defensive uh idea the
queen now backtracking along the b1 uh
to h7 diagonal and if the queen ever
just sits on f5
looks to me as though the two knights
and the queen are doing a sufficient job
there to hold the position together
not only that you've got to be a little
bit careful here as white sometimes
you uh you know
have
you focus all of your attention on the
king side but the b5 pawn is a target
the d4 pawn is a target some knight f5
appears some rook a4 appears
all of a sudden
you know you could be
you know a bit overstretched a bit
overextended so this is certainly not a
position which uh
and you know to my eyes looks crushing
for white and the evaluation bar
confirms it it just says that this is
equal and in fact i have to say even
though i'm you know i've been on the
white side of these structures all my
life
playing against french's and whatnot
um i would take black here maybe that's
my age showing robert that
you know
i would prefer the defensive task
well it's funny you say that because
while i am a person who goes against the
french defense every time i see it i'm
like why would somebody do it this was a
carrot con but the
underlying pawn structure is great in
the french because a pawn chain is only
as strong as its base pawn so this
little chain here from d4 to e5 the d4
pawn can become a target whereas f7 if
say the queens get traded is very hard
to get to now with queens on the board
watch out for a sacrifice in the e6
square because if you're not looking
carefully you can be hit with a knight
takes e6 or a knight takes f7 with
knight takes e6 to follow kind of stuff
and you might get checkmated so that's
why mel kumyan is spending so much time
right now he understands that if he
takes with a knight maybe knight f4 to
h5 to f6 it could be very dangerous for
his king so with these queens still on
the board lawrence
mel kumian can never rest easy and he's
doing the right thing by spending a
bunch of time on this recapture
yeah and actually which way to capture
on g6 is also not at all clear to me
which knight
is better and again that's why franz is
investing so much time here kramnik with
a nice three-minute advantage he goes
with the e-night which is actually the
night i expected because the f knight
protects
e6 knight h5 as you said
but can we
can we just ignore it and play queen of
five i know it's ugly to ruin our pawns
like that but i feel as though i know we
then dropped d5 sorry that probably
isn't very good
excuse me
right because the easter eggs are not
doing an important job
okay this is a tricky spot fran
he's down to three minutes 45 he needs a
good move here
um does he want to play nineties no
knight d7 knight takes e6
and then there is there a knight takes
e5 it gets
it's all getting a bit crazy
lawrence i would not want to have this
from the blacks i know we were just
saying that if yeah we have accurate
defense we may be able to then go on and
uh play well in the ending but this is
so scary with both these knights sitting
here and as you pointed out queen f5 i'm
just gonna put this on the board that
looks like a natural defensive move but
after the queen swap we lost our great
pawn structure and that pawn was
defending d5 which means knight f6 check
follower knight takes d5 already wins
upon which is what you were uh
indicating before so i do think that mel
khumyan is getting in time trouble he's
down under three minutes that may seem
like an eternity in online chess but in
this position you may find yourself
checkmate in a few moves
yeah absolutely and uh when i was uh
alluding to the defensive task let me
just put in a caveat i need two hours on
my clock to be able to defend this
because there are so many night jumps so
many sacrifices
a lot of
ideas actually for white in this a very
rich position
uh in terms of attacking motifs so i do
not envy plant's task here feels very
very tricky and as you said serious time
trouble and a bit of pressure now
vladimir kramnik up five minutes on the
clock
um two seconds increment only this is
not a 15 plus 10 game where you know the
10 second increment really is massive
because you bash out five six moves in
row it's already another minute two
seconds on the clock
and
really struggling here
seems as though you can't see things too
clearly and
big big trouble in my opinion for
mel kumian
yeah i agree with you here lawrence that
just based on his clock mansion and
there he goes 97 immediately the eval
bar shoots up because that is in fact a
blunder you were mentioning knight takes
e6 that looks like it's very possible
right now because if that pawn would
take back on e6 in comes the white queen
with check the knight on d7 is loose and
loose pieces drop off so kramnik with
seven minutes he is able to spend some
time before going for a knight takes e6
move but it looks like he will find it
and as much has been said lawrence about
how krumnick struggles in online play
how he sort of played rapid chess
championship than immediately quit
because he lost on time in a few
different games he played very well he
started something like four and a half
out of five he was out playing everybody
even in the final round against vincent
kymer he was completely winning before
flagging so uh krumnik can play online
and he just needs that increment
yeah absolutely uh
and you know
even though he hasn't played
historically let's say
tons of online chess
it's not as if these guys are not used
to a computer screen these guys have
been using the laptops
for
decades and
can just as easily calculate
on on a 2d board compared to a 3d board
and grant in
in big trouble here knight takes e6
looks good
um not sure what kramnik is
trying to calculate
is he looking at let me put a variations
you know takes e6 robert
knight d takes e5 i want to give back
the piece like this d takes e5 f takes
e6
queen takes e6 king
uh
oh no i am getting amazing
no i'm just getting mated straight up
king of f8
king of fate might avoid mate but
even then i'm not really
avoiding it
i liked your reaction there though
because i had the same thing i was like
oh maybe there's this rebuttal and then
you immediately look at how it turns out
and even if there's no checkmate whites
up a pawn here with the safer king so it
feels like there it is knight takes e6
played by big vlad and he's going to
score dub in game one here
yeah i don't see any way malcolm young
can survive
this position on one and a half minutes
looks toast to me
um
well i don't even know what the best
defensive try here is
something like a rook
i mean i i'm desperate to get my rook
involved on a8 it's so unfortunate i
can't
can't find a root for it maybe rook a4
to threaten night day that's the move
isn't it rook a4 robert to threaten
knight d takes e5 a little cheapo to
ah
to try and make something work here i
think that's what we're gonna see you
actually think when you're low on time
you play rook a4 and pray that he misses
knight d65
after which suddenly
yeah did did we do that strong chess
player thing where we look at oh this
line wins upon us winning the game and
missed checkmate in like two moves
because after knight d takes e5 isn't
our knight f6 check uh for king h8 h5
mate
there is there is thank you
i only just recognized
that
i was just testing twitch chat because
obviously a lot of people are
uh
looking at this from uh from early in
the morning and by the way if this is
the position on the pool with rook j
this is exactly the sort of thing i was
trying to get previously where i've got
some counter play down the g file uh of
course it doesn't work but
there is one little trick here i want to
put this on the board knight f6 which
looks logical hitting the rook
threatening mate runs into knight f4
check
and if knight actually a queen g6
backwards queen move
out of the blue and all of a sudden you
get made it as white so you there is
still room to mess this one up
uh wow and um the sort of thing i would
you know if i wasn't the comp yeah
if i wasn't fully focused i could fall
straight into but rook g8
um so you actually need a move here as
white and let me suggest a move
queen h3 robert
runs into knight f4 check i am the worst
player in history thank you very much i
actually thought i could play knight's
exercise myself
um
and for all of you guys thinking i'm
using an engine i think that might be
your
uh your proof otherwise
uh yeah i'm gonna under a lot of
queensland i've got a feeling so what do
we do here robert actually hold on a
second why is this
why is this so easy
maybe it's knight g3 just bring our
knight back
block the line and i think that's the
problem in how i also think about these
positions is i'm going for checkmate
that's what i've been doing this whole
game but i have to realize i've won two
pawns i have enough extra material my e
pawn will start running the king on h8
in a world of trouble itself so bring
the knight back to g3 just to avoid some
kind of discovered check that might just
be the way to go so that we can
coordinate our pieces and make use of
our extra material
yeah so
tough position i mean
it can it can still go wrong here for
kramnik this is not a given
he's objectively winning but
practically speaking blunders are
possible
so
knight g3 knight four it seems is on the
board
king h2 okay
what a cold-blooded move by the way
is this so clear if i play for example
rook chase a rook g7 queen d8 check
and then queen h4 check okay so queen g6
makes a ton of sense
is there rook h1 here can i play quick
h1
when the king won me
it is actually it's one of my favorite
things in robert chess to give mate with
the king
king g1 mate uh the discovery checkmate
with the king is very pretty and rook h1
is gonna be very tough to stop
eight seconds
he's not gonna be able to even find a
move here five seconds gotta go
and three
two and he gets one off but king g one
doesn't that just win the game ninety
two check he wants
oh very clunky
yeah not too late to blunder king f1
would have been a blunder
well king of three rook takes g3
oh
wait a second
wow
goodness me
so king f1 is the only move
but good enough f1
is completely winning the knight covers
h1 kramnik plays it and mel kumyan loses
on time vladimir kramnik gets to a one
nil lead here in the a four game match
with a 15 plus two second increment time
patrol he takes the drink of water he
should be very happy about the start
here
yeah and they get a small break final
position here uh very simply winning for
white that the queen was lost and
there's no much uh not much point
carrying on but we've got another game
here
and is this the ding game i guess it is
right it looks like the thing
min game but totally winning for white
basically
it is winning for white but based on the
time
min is down on the clock but we also
know he's a very experienced player in
speed chest high patrols and he does
have a knight and one pawn for the rook
so if this knight can somehow get its
way towards the white king and left
chances but i love the move by dingler
and queen of d7 because rookie comes
next and the black king is hunted
okay queen have two good good resources
here queen f3 actually
would threaten a perpetual but queen e3
nicely spotted by
ding and now can you actually see three
check yes but i guess just king g8 and
now will he try rook e2 possibly
rook for e2 is that the cleanest
not fearing the queen trade
or has he got something yeah and that's
exactly what he does
you got it lawrence and here's the queen
trade and okay black has some chances
here with the activity this knight's
about to come to d4 c2 is loose and if
black can trade off both the a and b
pawn for the c pawn that will give
chances even though you're down in
exchange because not many pawns remain
on the king side
rook f2
trying to activate both rooks
but how to do it check and then
rook to c8 okay but a f or b4
ah this is what he wants he wants to
double on the f
on the seventh and this is what he's
preparing now he's also preparing g4 g5
or
in some positions
rook ff7 is a bit more
a knight d4
but here
oh
actually this is a bit careful rook f4
92 roxy for knight e3 check and hello
hold on a second this is not so easy to
see
oh oh oh all of a sudden me
min's winning
knight takes c2 it's all over
and look at min lee he is
in jubilation the fist pumps he has
defeated the number two rated player in
the world he came back from the dead in
that game lawrence
i can't believe what i've just seen i
was so surprised at how nonchalant
ding was
there i i'm just
i'm a bit shocked
i i he complete his sense of danger
completely failed him
and
just like that
min lee ran the hay born down the board
and it was too late i'm shocked at how
nonchalant thing was uh dealing with
that uh with that issue
and wow what a win
seriously unbelievable you made a great
spot rook f4 knight takes you rook c4
was likely a plan just to win this pawn
but then you see 93 check scooping up
this rook and black wins so i think ding
had that idea it wasn't going to work
out he freaked out and then lost the
game but i think rook f7 was the way to
go
yeah so you come down the back this way
precisely and that black king has still
actually got issues and in fact after
knight takes c2 robert here can you play
g4 with the idea of playing king h3 and
g5
and if black plays g5 you've got ah g5
here h5 has never mate that's the
problem
because the king goes back to g7 so okay
let's stop that one take one maybe you
just play rook c7 instead and if knight
e3 check you've got king f3 yes and
there's no way to save the pawn knight
b5 roxy five
uh
will inevitably win this pawn and yeah
and with the white king so close
probably is technically winning
wow wow wow the what a finish to this
game by the way nihal sarn won his first
game against ralph mohmet we will dive
into that match as well uh you know we
just are getting our feet under us it's
a win for krumnik a win for neil saarin
and surprisingly a win for min lay he is
able to shock the world to take a lead
but it is a best of four match so we're
gonna take a quick break lauren tonight
we'll be right back for more from
chess.com global championship when we
return
[Music]
so
and we return here to the chess.com
global championship the first games are
in the books we've had three winners in
the first game of their matches vladimir
krumnick nihal sarin and surprisingly
min lay takes down dingley ren in game
one
yeah unbelievable stuff really ding had
a huge advantage he was coasting
um and
uh perhaps just got a little too
complacent too comfortable because um
you know he puts up a lot of resistance
he's a resourceful player
and
uh you know he
found a way to
uh to cause some practical problems and
ding just he just completely uh
mis-evaluated and
misinterpreted the position
ming's a pawn had to be dealt with and
he didn't and he just ran it down the
board and it was too late for din um so
a huge win in in game one with the black
pieces still time for ding to mount a
comeback uh nevertheless you have to
feel like min lee is in with a real
chance of
of causing i
could even be the biggest upset of the
first round
it's the first game that we've analyzed
of the entire round because of the
racing difference
um truly extraordinary stuff but game
two has already
started
and this time we're going to be focusing
on uh it looks like mahmed off against
sarin who we didn't really have a chance
to look at sarin did take the first one
so should we look at this one and then
maybe go over to ding if things start to
get a bit wild
yeah we'll keep a better eye on all
games going forward but right now we
have our eyes on this one here between
ralph mohammed of and neal sarah and if
we look at their ratings by the way
lawrence that mamado is actually the
higher rated player according to
chess.com rapid ratings now that
fluctuates some people play less than
others uh but for momento that should
give him the confidence he needs to
realize that he can strike back as good
as nihal soren is as young and talented
as everyone and knows uh that he is
raphael's experience and when you have
experience it means that you know how to
come back from deficits
absolutely
let's see how he does here ralph mehmed
off now with the white pieces it seems
uh let's get that game
up on the screen
yep we got it what's going on right here
we go
and a
kind of uh
a modest opening approach here by my
major but an approach that gained some
popularity in the past few years we've
all seen the mainline italian game
actually
in my opinion robert you might disagree
with me but i think it's taken over as
the main weapon against one e45 uh the
quantity of games we now see in the
italian compared to the spanish i think
demonstrates that
and
you know the main line italians still
discussed a lot when you play with d3
and c3 looking to play that slow game
but there's something to be said for an
early night c3 and you can see exactly
why this has been played by ralph named
off what he's trying to do is hunt this
dark square bishop down
via the move knight a4 and normally if
you're able to make that trade you can
claim that you've you've really gained
something there because that's a very
important bishop for black in these
italians and to exchange it for a night
and then say okay i've got the two
bishops and i can open up the position
things can happen but it seems as though
sarin not phased at all says all right
mate feel free take the bishop uh i'm
gonna trade off your light squared
bishop then you're gonna be just left
with one bishop and i've got a perfectly
solid position
um seems logical to me
yeah no i think your description is
great especially in light of a potential
second bishop coming off the board for
black because if we get this trade as
well
and you know i can just put this on the
board quickly and here we might see it
knight b6 ab6 what exactly is this
bishop on c1 doing that well this is the
live position so i'll just put this up
here these pawns for black all on dark
squares that limits the scope of white's
bishop and you're going to need a useful
diagonal so i like the start of this
game from nihal sauron's perspective i
also like the fact that he is not yet
castled i know your coaches have told
you castle quickly get the king to
safety early the king is perfectly safe
in the center and you're not sure yet
which side of the board it will be safe
from if you cast a king side there's an
open file for the rook coming to f8 but
now that white has castle's king side
maybe black can strike with the g5 g4
push at some point he says i won game
one i don't need to think about
aggressive intentions but the point was
that he had optionality there and all
chess players well they like to have
choices
yeah absolutely
we have a very orthodox position though
very orthodox
structure and it's going to be
interesting to see exactly what ralph
uh decides to do here because this is
the moment where ralph basically has to
decide on a medium-term plan how does he
want because he's almost got his pieces
developed yes he can play moves like
bishop d2 or bishop e3 but i'll tell my
students these are not really can moves
connected with a plan you know there's
in my opinion robert and again you might
disagree with me but i think there's a
big misunderstanding when it comes to
chess literature developing a piece
doesn't mean just getting it off the
back rank so if we went back and moved
there robert and played the move for
example bishop to um let's say bishop to
e3 i think this move actually doesn't
really help white might even hinder
white because when a d5 push comes your
bishop then can get in some trouble some
tempe is being lost so when you think
about developing a piece guys and you
know especially a lot of you players
watching improving clothes really try
and ask yourself is it connected with a
plan or are you just getting it off the
back rank because a lot of the time
getting it off the background doesn't
quite work and we now see
exactly what a grand master thinks he
says no i don't want to just put my
bishop somewhere random i want to put it
on a in a position with purpose and i
really like the move b4 ralph is saying
he wants to put the bishop on b2 on the
long diagonal and then if he can ever
open up that diagonal wire move like
pawn to e4 suddenly the bishop is going
to do its job which is perform along an
open long diagonal bishops like long
open diagonals
why not put it there that's the
difference between a grand master
way of thinking and you know something
you know an improving club player
or am i being overly critical
no i think it's a great point that
instead of just simply developing the
bishop on the diagonals on he makes a
move that causes nihal to think because
knight takes b4 is technically possible
the rook on a1 is loose so why would
mamedov give away a pawn no it's not a
gambit this queen needs to protect the
rook for a takes b4 to be a possibility
how does the queen get to protect the
rook when like bishop takes h6 opening
up black's king in the process so who
won this pawn trade white clearly did
because black lost the defender whereas
white lost this pawn on the side of the
board it's not really doing all that
much so that is why ralph metal plays b4
and get away with it and lawrence he
highlighted the position very well that
this bishop will likely come to b2 when
we play d4 our bishop will actually have
some scope along the board's longest
diagonal rather than just sitting on e3
staring into brick walls in both
directions
precisely yeah
so now it's on nihal he's got a decision
to make um
what should black be doing well there
are two ideas here would it be a little
bit careful you can't advance d5 so
easily because it looks as though the
move b5 might come not sure how clear
that actually is but you don't want to
start unnecessarily giving up horns in
the center again you can connect the
rooks
by some standard moves
um
i wonder if we're going to see
a move like uh
does that move pawn to b5 actually makes
sense
you prevent
uh b5 yourself to kind of fix the
structure on the
queen side but then i guess neil i was
thinking
does white in some positions have some
c4 that might not be possible because
the e4 is hanging
b5 feels like a
pretty typical move uh you probably hate
it robert but it's on my radar
i don't hate it at all i think it's
actually a completely natural type of
move and it does stop white's progress
and you cement this pawn in place this
is a semi-open file so the rook on a8
will stare down this pawn a3 that cannot
move from there i think another move
that i think is knight e7 to g6 things
like that a queen e8 is standard as well
just trying to get this queen on the
diagonal because there's no f7 pawn
blocking its path so those kind of moves
all come to mind along with your b5 push
i think that nihal is doing just fine
but he's working right now to come up
with a plan he doesn't just want to make
moves he wants to make sure he actually
has a plan so that when ralph presses
forward trying to gain some momentum he
is in time to stop
all of his opponents ideas
absolutely and
i think we should go move on
okay let's go there
dingly ran the black pieces against min
well we tune in here it looks like a
pretty symmetrical position lauren so
what caught your eye
well nothing
especially caught my eye here it's a
very standard looking position ding is
of course at doing absolutely fine here
he's got perfect piece coordination in
this symmetrical queen's gamut accepted
kind of structure very difficult to make
progress here as white uh the reason i
wanted to come to this particular game
was simply because
i feel as though it's uh you know an
important bounce-back game or
opportunity here for ding a loss is a
catastrophe
a loss here would mean that minlee would
only need a draw out of the last two
games
uh and i think
psychologically speaking it would be
very difficult for ding to bounce back
so i'm curious how he approaches this
position i don't think he's just going
to want to halve out here i think he's
going to just try and outplay his
opponent how he does that well if i knew
the question the answer to that robert
i'd be 26 50. um that's the uh that's
the problem i mean to make progress in
these positions to make these little
moves these little improvement moves is
one of the finest arts in chess
um
and you know for example in this
position it's not at all clear to me
you know i want to play
i mean how ridiculous is the move queen
a7 to put the queen on a8 here i guess
it's insane but
maybe i've had more insane ideas i don't
know
what's your what kind of candidate moves
are you looking at here robert with the
black pieces
i don't think that's completely out of
the question so uh for you made a number
of good points there and dingly wren is
maybe
a top two player in the world by rating
obviously but in terms of these types of
positions the way he beat hikaru
nakamura in the final round of the
candidates is just a position like this
where it looks completely even and he
was able to find ways to just poke and
prod and cause his opponent some issues
so i don't think that bringing the queen
to the long diagonals out of the
question i think that what ding is
trying to consider is a move like b4 a
good idea trying to open up the line
from the queen on b6 the
uh should this knight on d7 start
hopping into the game with knight to c5
maybe that knight lands the b3 at some
point uh but
these advantages for black you sees 0.2
in black's favor they're very small and
i think the reason why i would prefer
black is because of square control if
you notice the pawn structure on the
queen side black has control over the c4
square a white has a hole on b3 that
could be a problem later in the game and
the side that controls the pawn breaks
is often the side with the advantage who
controls the pawn breaks here it's black
with the potential b4 move so that's
seems minor and it is but in terms of
trying to come up with more than just
splitting the point as you were saying
that ding wants to accomplish well you
just need to look at your small pluses
and try to maximize them
and rookie 8 played so
ding's saying
okay uh
maybe now he wants to follow up with
some knight c5 because he wanted to
avoid
uh two too many trades
i'm still in
kind of
liking this yeah he does go 95 this is
clearly very logical and now a knight
can land on e4
um at the right moment so
what is minlee gonna do here i like
does the move bishop e5 make any sense
here robert to just try and plant this
bishop sometimes on d4 and just
anticipate a knight e4 jump i don't know
what you think about that one
looks very reasonable and that's the
thing about these positions is that you
tend to have like seven different moves
that all look good and that can cause
you to burn clock or it can cause you to
misstep because you get a bit nonchalant
about things you're like ah that looks
good that looks good it's all the same
and there's no tension in this position
none at all and that's why i think min
is trying to figure out is this bishop
e5 maneuver strong bringing the bishop
d4 i really like it because the bishop
one g3 isn't doing all that much uh
other moves that come to mind
potentially i was about to say covering
the b3 square
with bishop c2 right away i wasn't
necessarily expecting but it does make
sure that knight has no forward progress
yeah bishop c2 played
so now the question is is ding gonna
just float in on e4
possibly um are there other ways to
make progress here
uh
most likely
yeah maybe
maybe there's like knight d5 as well
just because you were saying white might
want a bishop on d4 i think black would
also like a bishop on d5 so
these kind of trades sort of trading
white's most active piece could be good
and he takes your advice and brings
knight to e4 similar idea
okay
so knight e4 indeed played
what do you think do you think ming is
gonna is gonna hold this one
uh robert or do you think ding is gonna
find a way to eke out some kind of
advantage in bishop i played
i think that min's in great shape here
and uh dingley wren he can be perfectly
content with the draw that's the thing
about when you are trailing in a match
and it's a four game match he does not
have to win this game and i think
dingley wren wesley so these are the two
of the best players on the planet and
not losing their nerve they understand
that there will be two games remaining
so you don't need to go all in in this
one especially once it's symmetrical
position so what dingley red is going to
do is now may bring that queen to b7
your idea from earlier lawrence it's not
going to come back to c5 at some point
bishop to c4 i do like the inroads that
dean is making i think he is slightly
better here i prefer his position and
it's just one of these things that it
may look completely even but when you
take your eyes off the calculation then
all of a sudden things get a bit
yeah
queen b7 on the board as you mentioned
robert now lining up down that long
diagonal and
yeah
progress being made here by dingler and
this is an instructive game potentially
all of you guys who you know played
queen's gambit accepted or uh some some
similar systems and have been wanting to
to find out how to press with black
dinglerin is giving you a free lesson
here this is the sort of thing you need
to do
incremental
sort of uh improvements it's it's not a
rush if you start rushing in these
positions it always backfires
as robert said there isn't the tension
available
for you to just go and blast things open
so you have to just slowly slowly
improve your pieces talk to your pieces
ask them are you doing the job you want
to do are you applying maximum pressure
are you being efficient
that's what the great players do in such
positions amino plays a move which
i guess he wasn't that happy about
playing
but maybe just couldn't find anything
uh
sort of uh better which is b4
and this of course now gives up with the
four square permanently for a black
piece either a bishop or a knight the b4
and a3 pawns are also a bit more
vulnerable
but i guess the idea of this move is
that min actually wants to retreat the
bishop from e5 right out the way either
on a1 or b2
give
himself some more space to jump in on on
the dark squares in the center
um
that's how i would interpret that move
robin
good interpretation oh you know takes
away that c5 night jump which kept
bothering
min so this position looking pretty
level for now we'll come back to it if
something interesting occurs but i'm
looking at the kramnik game because
mokumeon well he needs to strike back
and so as we head on over here between
kramnik and melchymian look at this
lawrence black is actually down upon for
the time being because white with seven
black with six but i guess krumnik's
claim is that this e5 pawn is not so
long for this board but bishop takes f3
on the horizon
precisely yeah uh i don't think kramnik
is going to be too unhappy here because
i don't think there is a way for white
to hold on to that pawn
um
and
yeah so rook d2
you're not obliged to take immediately
on f3 here you can play move like rook
fe-8 first if you wanted to
because knight d6 you could probably
even play rogue takes e5 maybe he
doesn't want any of that maybe he does
just want to simplify matters take on f3
take on e5
and see what's going on
looks completely fine to black to my
eyes
but then again i've got a very poor
grasp over the
the nuances of this this kind of
catalan um
what would you do
i think you're being a little hard on
yourself because i think your intuition
was correct like the fact that so many
people would immediately take on f3 and
then immediately take on e5 but you're
suggesting here that that's not going
anywhere that maybe there are improving
moves to make and kromnic makes one of
them and i think what this illustrates
if we just show
a sample line was that if bishop takes
f3 was played instead after say bishop
takes f3 or queen takes f3 i'm not sure
it totally matters how you capture back
with but then take on e5 white plays
this move rook d1 and suddenly you have
to contend with rook d7 and you cannot
play rook to d8 because if you play rook
d8 after all the pieces are traded your
bishop on e5 is hanging and white goes
up a piece so your intuition was perfect
there lawrence you uh suggested a
improving move instead of rook e it was
d8 just to trade off pieces on the open
file and now kramnik
at his lizard can take this pawn e5
yeah well well uh
wall pointed out there uh
robert
and uh there has been a trait it seems
and wow
a move i did not expect by kramnik
but it looks as though there might be
some concrete reason for it b5
attacking the knight
and
if
there's a trade
and a knight floats into d6
what does kramnik want to do there
can i just say something before i answer
the question of the position can can
vladimir keep playing chess
can we you know sign a petition for that
because the way he's handling this
position you could see to the side of
the board here it says zeros after this
sequence of moves he's clearly so darn
strong and who doesn't want to see big
vlad duke it out with the best players
in the world so i don't know who's gonna
start that petition but somebody please
get on it
yeah i mean uh
you know such a great player such a
such a um
you know i think his
uh
contribution to chess is often
understated or undervalued i mean this
man from the opening stage to
mill game ideas his contribution has
just been huge
um and i know a lot of people miss uh
seeing him play because he can still
clearly play at the very top level
if he wanted to i'd be really curious to
hear what you think his rating would be
if he just kind of came back if he had
three months of prep i think he would
still be over 2700 easily actually i
think it would be a
2750-ish
maybe around that area wouldn't surprise
me
um
but you know
he's he's also done everything i think
he thinks he can do
in chess he's he's been world champion
he's
he's been world number one he's won
olympiads
what else is there left to achieve in
chess and you know he's got a family
so it's probably going to be difficult
to tempt him back
especially when he can win just 200
grand
sitting at home with a nice cup of
coffee and
you know
his his uh
uh his um filtered water on on tap so
uh
it's gonna be hard um and i think he's
gonna take this tournament extremely
seriously as well uh that's my
impression so
let's see in his position it's just fine
yeah
opposite yeah in fact
i was gonna say i prefer his position
he's got chances with the outside pass
pawn i think that it's easier to go
wrong for white than it is for black
because there's no targets in black's
position b5 maybe it's a little bit
loose but i don't see it as being any
looser than this pawn on b2 so
king g2 played by mel kumyan and the
biggest problem i would say for uh
harant is that
he needs to win and you can't just beat
krumnik on demand that's something that
all the best players in the world have
been working on for decades at this
point so i i just think that kronbic is
playing the perfect match right now
yeah i love the way uh crown nick is
playing
at the moment uh
very very nice controlled
doesn't have any serious
uh practical issues to deal with in this
position
feels as though france pieces are not
really
working that well kramnik has still got
a bunch of
moves improving moves he can make
i would actually take black here quite
comfortably in a in a real game i think
um
you know but everything in black's
position is
is
is what is fine and well
and you know
i wonder if he's going to play the move
h5 here that's the move i'm
it's a little bit loosey-goosey it's
completely unnecessary
but i just want to you know have i well
what can i say
that is a round of applause for you
lawrence trent because you absolutely
call that one
yeah
um no i the reason this is a this move
has got two main ideas firstly prevents
knight g4 jumps which might spark a
little bit of initiative knight g4 and
e5 ideas by grant trying to
activate his pieces whilst deactivating
that bishop for example on g7 and second
idea is now some bishop h6s suddenly do
appear in some positions and this pin
can be a little bit awkward sometimes
often
even here the trade of bishop for night
uh leads to some interesting middle
games uh so
clan decides to go
rook to d7
um
so
[Music]
wow why can't i take this pawn
i think well e5 was going to be ah
and i mean i really love the way
kromak's doing this he's just saying
that uh you know i'm not going to give
you any semblance of an initiative no
attack nothing to target if you play
rook d5 now thinking you're going to win
this b5 pawn kromnik's idea is that now
queen takes b2 is a queen trade because
you will win b5 but with the liquidation
kramek saying i have no chance to lose
this game so i love what vlad is doing i
think we can trust him to hold this
we'll keep an eye out on it of course
but i think we should go over the game
to nihal sarin and
because that game is heating up some all
of a sudden he's rook landed on e5 from
what i saw of course as always the eval
bar says that there's nothing in zeroes
but look at nihal's clock lawrence
yeah niall way down on the clock and
kind of
surprising and his position for me
even though the eva bar might say zeros
here i think you take white all day in
this position with this silly looking
knight on h5 the f5 pawn is weak
uh here you can play a move like rook
fe1 for example and it's absolutely not
clear at all to me how you're supposed
to unravel here is black because f4 runs
well f4 just drops a knight a bigger
pattern you can't
so after rook fe won what is black's
idea maybe just to play g6 but then you
weaken your king so
i mean i expect rook fe1 here by ralph
and ralph is you know he's got the the
patented t-shirt in mouth
uh position which is more of a an online
at home position um very rarely over the
board you see a guy with his t-shirt in
his mouth
but
ralph clearly sensing
that this is a moment here for him to
uh to get back in this match
um and i think he's favorite he needs to
find a couple of good moves
and he does play rook if he won
yeah
as i said lauren said we know how good
knee hell is not i mean good is the
understatement of the century how
amazing nihal is at speed chess he did
win two matches in last year's speeches
championship uh he's one of the best
online players in the world he's also up
upon i actually missed that fact that he
is a pawn ahead and if he can win this
game all of a sudden with black rook
coming to d6 hitting the knight on d4
and the pawn behind on d3
uh watch out because then he might just
lock this match up
i'll be honest i also didn't think he
could support up which is a huge detail
actually in such a position every pawn
does count he's also now got a root back
for his knight white does not have a way
to take advantage of the seventh rank
because rookie 7 just runs into a very
simple brook f7
the uh trading of of rooks clearly helps
black if black is a pawn up and actually
i see no real way here and ralph if you
caught that there with the um what i
like what do you call the what is it the
horse side
robert you know the one
yeah
right he did he let out a horse sigh
which is uh it's
it's it's not a great feeling to do that
because you're just looking at this
position saying damn i'm actually out of
ideas here
um
i can't find
an improving move 96 also runs into rook
f7 and if you start getting uh really
creative like 98 that runs into rook d7
and if you start taking a pawn on b7
then your knight is actually trapped
suddenly randomly on b7 and black there
could just consolidate with knight f6
doesn't even have to take the d3 pawn
yeah i think uh i think ralph is
frustrated here to say the least
yeah well
uh ralph might break the internet if he
loses this game and goes down two nil to
niall sarin but
lawrence all of a sudden i'm looking at
the dingly wren game against minlai
while we will keep an eye on every game
as best we can but that game it looks to
my eyes like ding you know he's trying
to do a little something something over
there he has his pawn all the way down
a4 he has the pair of bishops and if you
look at the evaluation it's getting
better for black
yeah and this is exactly how i was
thinking this game was going it was the
momentum was definitely in ding's favor
and even with the exchange of rooks
these two bishops in this kind of ending
pawns on both flanks sides of the board
a weak pawn on h4 an advanced fixed
structure on the other side let me tell
you this is no fun to defend it might
objectively already be losing for white
here because
black is going to be able to establish
the the the concept of two weaknesses
in my opinion at some point f3 is going
to be weak or g3 is going to create
another weakness the a3 pawn is a
permanent weakness
and white doesn't have a way to attack
any of black's pawns that's the big
point the b5 and a4 pawns are easily
defendable h5 is easily defendable g7 is
out the way black's king
is also much more active you need an
active king in the end game got to be
careful here king d5 would be a huge
blunt because it runs into 93 check so
of course
we see a correct move here from ding e4
and now you're just creating all of
these gaps all of these little openings
now he's going to target the g3 pawn
and i see
a ding win here i do not see a way for
minli to objectively
hold this position
i mean it's just too gross
um
so you can go g6 here if you want
you can probably
yeah
sorry lawrence i was just going to say
that all of these pawns on dark squares
for
white that's the big problem is that
there's this bishop on e7 which isn't
doing all that much just yet but here's
step one bishop d6 hitting g3 is that
going to force the knight back to f1
then bishop d3 kicks that knight out of
there in fact white's just losing all of
his pawn demeter and min shakes his head
he's dead lost
yeah
and the the biggest problem min has yeah
and he just understands
hands up in the air is that after knight
f1 bishop d3 black can happily trade
bishop tonight because it's not an
opposite colourful spending bishops of
the same colour also h4 just falls very
quickly i actually expect resignation
from here by men save your energy
you have zero chance the pawns are
falling and look how quickly that
position just
the collapse there robert maybe by might
be shocking some people when just five
moves ago oh we have any um sort of uh
equal position equal material end game
how bad can it be
that's the difference you know ding
understanding that the two bishops cause
havoc
on this board
um in this kind of structure with the
the fixed weaknesses yeah bishop d3 okay
min now just playing out of frustration
bishop's h3 knows three now even bishop
b4 here is not a blunder because knight
g5 check king of f5 is still easily good
enough for the win
um you can do and actually i think ah
but bishop b4 knight d4 check you don't
want to give unnecessary chances because
b5 hangs
probably just king f5 here
and if king d2 can you just go bishop f1
or something yeah just run the king to
g4
looks like a fairly straightforward
victory
yeah it kind of seems like a lot of
things win the one thing you need to
avoid which is what you were um
indicating is that you can't allow
bishops of opposite color because even
if you win this h4 pawn if they're
opposite code bishops that's how min has
a chance to survive so dingler
centralizes king the bishop comes to f6
to provide another defender of h4 and i
just want to give a shout out to dingley
wren because he lost game one in
frustrating fashion the eval bar had him
at something like plus four he was up in
exchange for a while and then he somehow
loses uh the thread and the game and so
for him to bounce back in this manner
with playing a clean game those are the
best types of games when it almost seems
like you've done nothing like he just
made very natural moves but that's just
how strong he is that his just casual
moves are stellar and he does in fact go
obstacle bishops he takes the second
pawn away distracts the bishop from 94
and lawrence he sees his way through
this he knows he's winning the resulting
ending
yeah two pawns is just too much
especially when there are two other
pawns on the other side of the board
white would love to put together some
kind of
fortress but you just aren't able to do
it king c4 here yeah and king into b3 is
just
really
impossible you can try bishop g5
yeah but this is nowhere near enough
king b3 and now it's a third pawn
that's just
not even not even close with three pawns
okay yeah and the king comes out by by
b1 as well you can
yeah it's it's time to resign here as
mainly yeah
and
wow
on cue
big win for uh for dingler him right
back in it
yes and lawrence i'm just going to bring
up the final position from mel kumian
kramnik because it was checkmate on the
board somehow kramnik alert the white
king up to h4 and delivered a checkmate
in this position we left off like around
here
and i guess brought knight into d4 and
this simply outplayed him thanks to h5
and h4 so your h-pawn idea lawrence had
paid dividends for kramnik
certainly did and kramnik now with a
commanding lead
you tend to feel as though
this is probably the end of the road for
france
um
kramnik only needs half out of two and
even if he were to lose the two games
he is guaranteed a
a spot in the uh well in the uh tie
breaks
we're not we're going to get there in my
opinion i think krantz is just being
outclassed by
you know a better player
and
uh
sarin also drew with mahmud there so
sarin did hold that position
uh even with his uh
his time situation he won't be too
unhappy to hold with black
so
you know basically
well i'm happy because my bracket is
looking pretty good here now uh robert i
have to say i was a bit concerned that
my 100k dream
uh would be already done and dusted but
uh ding coming back there just so people
know for full transparency
i've got ding
kramnik and sarin today
uh to qualify
yeah those are definitely the popular
picks and right now kramnik up two nil
one and a half to half and it's dingley
wren who's in a tough battle with min
lei the very popular uh chess content
creator recently minted grand master
from vietnam so as we return in a few
minutes there's more to come in the
opening matches here at thechest.com
global championship we'll be right back
so
[Music]
welcome back everybody
global championship we have two games in
the books three matches on
progress alongside the international
masters
lawrence we've had some great games
yeah uh
we've had uh
some uh
some well i guess predictable
uh ups and downs uh thus far
uh the biggest being uh the match of
dingler in against min lee dingler in
losing with the white pieces in the
first match really unexpectedly but
was able to bounce back in game two
meaning that match is currently tied
with two games to go remember it's the
best four games so two and a half points
will mean that you go through um in the
other match kramnik is uh taking grand
malcumin doesn't look like kramnik has
had any issues thus far but whatsoever
and nihal sarin are with an advantage
over ralph mahmedov so so far
uh the the uh the favorites of the match
is not in any serious danger in my
opinion the games have kicked off though
so robert
let's go straight in dingler in against
min lee
ding playing now a much more familiar
way of chess dingler in is a 1d4 player
almost i would say
exclusively so when he played e4 in game
one i was very very surprised
yeah he's going
back to his main repertoire and he's
doing much uh like what ralph momentum
did in the previous game he has given
his opponent double pawns taking a pair
of bishops so this is standard opening
fair and in
[Music]
is
yeah i i haven't got much experience
playing these systems either with white
or black
uh but i have seen a lot of games
recently and it feels as though white
has been doing really well in these
systems uh you've got the two bishops
you've got the central
majority and as you said uh robert if
you are able to
favorably expand and push
you can get quite the initiative as well
so
yes black is solid yes black has got
that typical slav
kind of uh
robustness about his structure
but
i've never been a fan of it
and
i fully
expecting to be
happy with how this current position is
lots of chances here for ding to do lots
lots of different ideas as well i mean
he's
he's got a fair amount of flexibility
here in terms of how he wants to set up
so
we'll be curious to see how that one
goes
yes early stages of this game
i'm looking at the other games as well
vladimir if he draws
just one of the next two games he moves
on here at the uh
global championship so um
should we go over to that game
absolutely
what is going on here
well we have a position i'm much more
familiar with this will
have come from a rossolimo sicilian with
a quick b4
um yeah
and this move d3 is a cool little move
that i've
i i'll i'll say i've done a little bit
of work on it i won't lie uh d3 e5 and
a3 exactly this position uh knight e7 i
believe and b4 and this is actually a
very very
uh
cool system the idea being that
after c takes before a takes b4 it looks
as though black can win a pawn with
knight x before that can but the move
bishop a3 is particularly troublesome
for black you can't protect the knight
easily
um for example well a5 just loses a
piece because of the pin
uh along the a file so you have to
actually move the knight back to c6 and
now the point of this idea which is to
put this bishop
into the heart of the black position on
d6 really as a kind of
uh sort of cork in in the black position
and um if you run this on the engines
this is really really tough to play you
can't move the bishop you can't move the
knight wire's got all of these improving
moves
um you know you can put the knight bd2
knight c4 exists
all kinds of stuff i mean even castles
in the worst case scenario you can even
chop on c6 and take on e5
and
the computers tend to like this position
for white so
that's why i believe
the move d6 was played exactly but now
white is able to take on c5
take
bishop g5 queen a5 i believe is the
position
um
yeah and
okay it's a very unclear kind of
position
so the question is what is kramnik i
think kremlin is going to play the move
a4 here with the idea of them following
up with knight a3 knight c4 or knight b2
knight c4 even knight p2 knight b3
exists
um
i think he would rather play this
position without playing a4 because it
gives black a few more squares
but
that's what i would envisage
or you could drop to c4 with the bishop
castles but now what is the question do
you just go 92 here anyway with white
maybe you do
yeah i mean 92 simple development things
like that
it all could be okay here for definitely
uh so
uh
we can absolutely uh imagine something
like that and as for black
what black is supposed to do here
uh is
it's very unclear at least black has got
the
uh
the sort of uh
the uh
the change in structure he needs
in order
to
make something happen remember from
kumian is down to zero he needs to win
this game
and he needs to win the next game if
he's going to remain in this tournament
so he absolutely
must
uh win and he's got the sort of position
where at least he can start
playing for that kind of win so queen d2
on the board
i now fully expect grant to keep the
queens on somehow but even that is not
completely clear queen c7 runs into some
knights he threes ideas and if he has to
go back to d8 also self-pinning it's not
ideal but he understands that
it's a situation which
requires him to take some additional
risks
now knight d5 is coming and this is a
big problem
because there's no f6 move and in fact
he's starting to look at this position
and i think he's thinking uh oh do i
have to play bishop e6 here
might be the only move
bishop e6 is a very very sad move to
play so he goes bishop g4 instead to go
after f3 but i like the pressure that
white is building knight d5 at any
moment could be a nuisance to deal with
the h6 square under white's control f6
would then be under white's control as
well so uh to win this game from the
black side that's what mel kumian needs
to do
but it's looking like it's not a very
fun position for him
yeah absolutely
okay so uh let's just keep an eye on all
the games i'm gonna just hover over some
of the others to see what's going on
there we don't want to miss in even a
moment and
maybe this is a good time to
venture over to another one if we can so
i'm going to pull up the game between
neal saarin and ralph
okay white is up a pawn that's neil
sarin and lawrence i've never had a
great grasp of these positions where you
give away to c5 pawn and then just claim
uh all is well in the position i have
the bishop pair and a good dark square
bishop but it is a pawn
yeah
um
again this looks like this is a position
from a
a rossolimo a similar opening to one of
the other games we've just seen
uh this time with a more classical
uh system with um
bishop e5 g6 castles and the like
uh and
uh yeah as you said uh sort of grasping
this
uh where the compensation is
um for these for the for the porn here i
think years and years ago
the the compensation was appreciated
more and nowadays you've got nihal sarin
part of the computer generation who just
says
excuse me a pawns pawn um show your
compensation
i don't really believe you've got
objectively enough and he might be right
um that being said
you know mamedov grew up in in
in an era where
you know
you could imagine the likes of
kasparov playing these kinds of
positions getting that dynamism
um
you know
all kinds of grandmasters
who could
and
it's
you know if you don't know this inside
out it's still a little bit tricky for
white like how are you supposed to set
up here you can't play knight c3 because
you dropped a c5 pawn
you can't play bishop b3 because you
dropped the e4 pawn
so what are you supposed to do you can't
play b4 because you open up that
diagonal and something will happen
so what exactly are you supposed to do
in this position
you ask an excellent question that you
know will have to give us the answer to
maybe you can just develop a bishop all
the way out to g5 or to f4 those are two
other viable options but the opponent's
e5 it can be targeted quite quickly so
uh it's really
playing around that pawn b6 will
immediately apply pressure the pawn c5
is pinned and after b6 it could be
bishop b7 to fall and this is this new
generation as you were mentioning
lawrence knight b to d2 what a difficult
move to play uh because you're locking
in your bishop on c1 you're actually
just
making sure you can't develop but
perhaps rook b1 followed by b4 is on the
horizon maybe e5 for white at some point
and then his knight can jump out to e4
or to b3 to protect the c5 pawn so
perhaps that's what knee hall is going
for
yeah and i wonder if ralph now is going
to play the move b6 trying to say look
there's a pin down the c file
you can't take because you're queen's
hanging if you go knight b3 then i'm
going to put my bishop on b7 and i'm
going to try and get maximum output for
my bishops
along the long diagonal pressurized e4
that looks like a
fairly
sort of
standard way
of
playing this position
um
how else maybe even the move a5 here is
it's a little bit loose isn't it i mean
you can't play knight c4 easily because
of queen takes c5 and i'm trying to
anticipate knight b3
uh
and by running this acorn down the board
and he does none of that of course and
he plays the move
this should be six bishop
bishop e6 it develops it allows for a
rook c8 and x to increase the pressure
on the c5 pawn uh but it also has the
possibility of running into a knight d4
at some point what do i mean by that
maybe knight b3 which preemptively
defends the c5 pawn and even if you
start going after the pawn there could
just be knight d4
next to fork the queen and the bishop so
i understand bishop e6 but i can also
see the downsides of it
exactly
so
knee hall i mean he's in great shape in
this match but he doesn't want to just
you know draw this game and try to draw
with black it's one of these positions
where he's probably feeling it you know
i mean we look at him on screen here
he's really diving into this position he
understands that he has some chances
here but he also knows that if he makes
some misstep black with the bishop pair
could have the upper hand so
ralph mohmet off and he's fully
concentrated as well and this is a
position with
a lack of clarity
yeah
um
you know nihal
much like his uh
his young colleagues are all incredibly
ambitious
so it's not as if in this position he's
trying to make a draw with white
um that's not the route he wants to go
she said robert you draw this
might happen might be a draw
but
you don't really want it because then
you have you've got a shaky last game in
black and
all kinds of things could happen right
so if he can put the match to bed now
that's definitely what he would want to
do
so
yeah curious uh
how how he'll play here
i'm i'm curious if there has been any
major
uh sort of developments in the other
matches though
yeah let's go on to the dingley ren game
against min because that one is tied one
point a piece so that match you know
thus far even and if you look at the
eval bar off to the side of the screen
here it says black is even better in
this game that is min lay the newly
minted grandmaster from vietnam very
popular shout out to man if our mods are
in the chat give him a shout out let's
follow his channel but right now i would
say the evaluation bar can be misleading
while black may objectively have a
slightly better position look at how
complicated this is there's a king in
the center uh it can you take this pawn
on d5 not very clear because a rook will
land on e1 and there could be pressure
and pins and after f4 is there going to
be an h5 at some point at f5 at another
point
lawrence i would not feel comfortable
with either color here
yeah it's a tricky one isn't it i think
i would still take white even though
black is objectively better just because
black's king is in the middle and
from a sort of a practical point of view
it might be slightly more difficult
also if you're a bit sloppy here with
black white suddenly does get a good
position pushed by three rookie one
comes and
all of a sudden you might be a bit tied
up
so
he does go for rook takes d5 which is
you know a
principled move
and
[Music]
yeah i guess after bishop f3 now the
problem is you can just trade on d1 and
castle
and say so what
uh
you've got nothing here is white which
is probably true
that's why i love dingley ren's move
lawrence he went rook
d
to e1 he says let's have more material
on the board because do you really want
to castle with h5
as my next move so even though black is
better uh by almost a pawn like his
upper pawn but if we look at the 0.7
evaluation this is actually quite scary
so it's good for admin that he has more
time and i have to say that the best
thing that's happening here is that min
is going to believe in himself when
you're playing dingley wren the number
two rated classical player on the planet
i believe he's also number one rated in
rapid chess according to fiji rapid
ratings if you lose game one you're like
okay i mean stinging the red what can i
do but when you win game one when ding
makes a mistake when you're in every
single match yes he just ground you down
but it was a close game
i feel like min just has that self
belief and as i see him on screen here
he's kind of chilling back near his fan
and
he might
really shock the world and take down
dingley wren
long way to go i i again
i don't i think three results are still
possible here
um
and
you know
i think the onus is still on
on mainly to prove that he can
uh that he can stay afloat
in such a position
the king is still
very very weak
so i'm not that bullish on
ming here he decides to castle like i
expect
and yeah an h5 exactly
now after h5 gh
why
can't i take back on h5 with the bishop
you almost certainly can
and i think that dang might and i'm
starting to wonder is there going to be
a rook takes g5 because black started up
a pawn so
now two pawns ahead but what if i take
on g5 give up an exchange and get my
queen over there my king will feel safer
i'm not sold on the idea but i'm just
as a defensive mechanism that's the type
of
move that i would be thinking about
maybe i need to give some material up to
safeguard my king
yeah
totally understandable
and could happen
didn't play h5 min immediately took
yeah and now ding is speaking again so
what's that all about
yeah that's that's exactly what i was
thinking like
what what what's the
uh
what's the delay for because
gh was kind of
almost uh
well close to being forced so i'm very
very curious
what's going on here
and
i'm looking at ding's connection it says
four bars i see him on screen here so i
don't think that's an issue and it
sounds like a joke but ding has had many
internet problems in online chess so it
does seem like he is fully connected uh
i hope although now that i'm yeah no
he's he's still there okay good i got
nervous yeah
he's still there
no he's he's trying to carry i'm not
exactly sure
what it is so he does finally play
bishop takes h5
really invested a few minutes there
and
i think min's like talking to himself
right now i saw his mouth moving he's
doing the hair twirling he's an olympic
level hair twirler so there are many of
those in chess uh david paravian uh he
like twirls all of his hair out but min
you know he's up there with the best of
him
but you know who the champion
twirler is robert of all people
if you just
no no it's not from the youth from the
us used to do it all the time uh the
champion hair twirler
it's not
uh
uh josh friedel but rather
vasily evangel but it's not the head on
his hair
that he twirls
it's this little eyebrow right there
[Music]
um
a man who has swolled more eyebrows than
anybody in the history of humanity
really he's got big thick bushy eyebrows
and
they're definitely twirlable
and if that's the way of
relaxing fair play
hey he's uh one of the absolute best
players of all time a living legend and
he is taking part in the chess.com
global championship he will face ray
robson in the opening round but that is
a future match right now
min has a predicament the h file is open
his king is on g8 is queen h2 about to
appear and that queen would love to land
down on h8 and deliver checkmate so i'm
with you that even though the evaluation
bar says zeros the burden of proof here
is definitely on min because his king is
in a world of potential hurt and i'm
worried for him
and he looks nervous absolutely
absolutely
and uh
yeah uh
min just struggling isn't he i mean it's
a sort of position where
you would much rather have it in a
classical game because it feels like you
have to find
uh really precise defense here
um and that's what i was saying before
that's why even though the engine bar
was in black's favor i didn't actually
believe that black from a practical
point of view was doing too well felt
like you have a very tricky task
and mainly
you can see
body language is a bit negative
slightly nervous
makes a bunch of sense
and ding on the other hand you know he's
got the vintage look of head in hands
really focused knowing that his queen is
about to go deliver some devastating
threats with queen h2 and look at me in
the calm move rook f to d8 doubling
along the d file giving the king perhaps
an escape route via f8 later in the game
but queen h2 that move still looks
somewhat worrisome
oh this is a really tricky position
yeah queen h2 looks incredibly dangerous
and i'm
very curious as to what black's
correct reply there is
because it doesn't look obvious to me
whatsoever
rook d2 runs into bishop e2
ah but now sorry rook d2 bishop rook
takes b2 check can i
oh my goodness you're just going for
checkmate aren't you
and you know gosh
i might yes it is
i think you do bring this rook in and
yes checkmate one is threatened but
after king c1
i think you're just queen
what and in the night the night hops 94
wow
oh my gosh all the pieces queen a4 check
and bishop a3
what a checkmating sequence knight
queen b4 and queen b2
that's actually incredible
and that's actually so easy to miss
yes
and that's actually why uh ding played
the move rook h2 his spidey senses were
really good he understood that
you know
he had to cover the second rank
so that so this is a very
uh clever move
but at the same time
it feels as though just for the moment
white is
kind of poorly coordinated somehow
um
with the back rank but we my spidey
senses are tingling but i
i can't make anything work
but i i know exactly what you mean
because rook h2 defends the second rank
also allows for rook e to h1 trying to
land that rook on h8 but look at this
from min lay playing the accurate queen
b4 queen takes e1 is the threat rook d2
is now available once more
i love the way he's handled this and we
can't forget that min is up upon here so
if pieces get traded off and the attack
is out the window then it's ding who
needs to survive because he's down
material
yeah absolutely
yeah it's
and it's it's very frustrating
to play these positions with white
because you're only
half a move away from delivering mate
but somehow your opponent finds
resources and finds
counter chances
i wouldn't be right right i wouldn't be
uh ruling a win out here for feminine
this can get very nasty and you can also
see ding is getting a little nervous
here visibly nervous
right
so yeah
very very tricky position indeed
fans around the globe they always root
for the underdog but then they
lament the fact that their brackets are
completely spoiled so a hundred thousand
dollars at stake if there is a perfect
bracket and if min wins the chances that
there will be perfect brackets when this
event is done are very similar rook h1
is a huge mistake according to the valve
bar he slides his rook over but what if
knight takes h5 takes hm
there is this mate threat so i
why is it so bad
is like
i know i'm never supposed to play the
move but i'm also wondering is there
like an f6 at the end there
oh and the bishop's trapped
oh my gosh we'll have to show us bring
up an announcement here
so we'll show this here after knight h5
rook takes h5 can i not play f6
wow
and queen h7 chick you just go king f7
and there's no
oh i mean king h7 somehow is wrong here
but that means king f8
is correct because if you give a check
then the king slides up right
that makes a lot of sense
oh
yeah
why is king f7 equal though like that's
the funny part is that looks like such a
logical move
right so
how is that suddenly a mistake because
rook d1 check is about to deliver check
me
fitness man what a weird position
oh i know what it is this is actually i
mean absurd stuff f5 so the bishop
defends backwards and if you you can no
longer take because there's checkmate if
the queen comes with g6 yeah so the
ascent essential difference is that if
the king were on and he played knight
takes h5 this might happen if the king's
f8 there's no f5 because you just take
the bishop and there's no queen g6 check
that's deep stuff honestly that the king
has to go to f8 rather than f7
lawrence is he gonna find it he is one
minute and now 18 seconds i think he is
because rook h8 is mate
and yeah there it is this could go
horribly wrong
dingler if he loses this match this game
he will have to win on demand
with the black pieces
and we could be looking at
our first major casualty
of this tournament
and you can sense
that mainly he's he can feel
you know the twiddling hair is
has doubled in speed and he's excited
and he's nervous and he's
all of those things
this is uh
you know
really really really interesting
in the meantime vladimir kramnik won his
third game in a row he is on to the
round of 32. congratulations to krumnik
and uh well for ron's mo cumin it was a
tough matchup he still goes home with 5
so uh he can hold his head high with a
nice paycheck but f6 played by minlai we
do have the matchup between nihal sarn
and ralph momento i have an eye on that
game it's looking uh like uh neal saarin
is made slightly better but even
material there so we should stick with
this one and as you point out lawrence
minlay twirling his hair he cannot stop
touching his head here but for dingley
wren
he's the one who needs to use every bit
of brain power to find a way out here
because he's lost according to the
engine and
queen h7 check if not for that move what
can you play because bishop h4 loses the
rook on h5
yeah and ding you know his his body
language has gone from okay i'm not
feeling great to pure panic mode and
queenie two played
i mean i don't mind this move because
there's a queen e6 czech ricochet mate
threat
so i don't mind this move i think it's
actually a pretty good
uh attempt
but uh
one thing's that there should be maybe
you just go king f7 here anyway just
protect the six square get out the way
how many of rook hates
um and if rookie one you've got
importantly queen takes e1 check maybe
that's worth
pointing out and rook d1
i'm not
very quickly just because lawrence made
a great uh move here rookie one queen
takes
trade queens in a fancy manner and when
all is said and done this rook moves
away this bishop is going to get trapped
so really nicely spot actually the
bishop is pinned for 5 winning on the
spots king of 7 min finds it he finds
king f7 and he is on the verge of
winning his second consecutive game with
the black pieces f5 played going queen
e6 mate but rookie
yeah that's it if rookie five is found
it's
it's just the end of the game and yeah
ding just not queen v6
allows bishop f4 at least
and you survive or bishop c1
give rookie five queen g4
wait the queen is going to get dangerous
queen
queen d3 doesn't mean
one
uh-oh
and look at minnie's looking nervous
down under 20 seconds queen g4 is played
what's he going to do how is he going to
survive his queen d3 check
and bishop f8 what a calm move under
tight pressure the king can run to e7
now
great move
now i think
ding is
you know still in
uh there are a huge amount of problems
here
but less than the other line would have
been
but what's it
and by the way nihal saharan down to
five seconds over in his game against
ralph mahmedov it seems like nihal is
doing just fine in fact has some
possibilities there uh so we will keep
our attention on this one as rook h7
lands watch out 15 seconds for min he's
got to move he takes his pawn allowing
rook g7 counter play
for
despite the material disadvantage
yeah and the point is the bishop is
going to come to f4 very very quickly
here
or rook h7 threatening mate but his back
rank is incredible oh what what is that
he wants rook team one over key one he
wants to go for the bishop
but there's
h
uh
but okay but
you're gonna draw this at the very best
but you might get away with the drawer
but what a let off for dingler in
who
can give another check here
and
yeah rook dd1 is coming
my word what a what a chance
for
and really going off the board now
what's he doing
f5
yeah
he wants
one
there's going to be king b1 and when the
rook comes on h
that might very well happen
but this black king can keep running i
mean it's not
entirely clear that the draw is forced
but it seems like there are just enough
checks for
ding to hold the balance so this is a
very dangerous situation maybe queen h6
as well to get this queen seven seconds
rook dd1 will be played
oh he's go he's allowing this
this yeah he goes queen c6 to keep the
king in ah queen c6
okay now min can
can dance around
but uh yeah it feels as though it's
going to be a draw
king f6 is there a way for black to lose
i don't think so the queen takes a six
questions
yeah not important
right
mainly four seconds check king e5 yeah
and this is gonna be a draw three time
repetition after king e5 wow
and min is disappointed
but he just drew
dingly around with the black pieces from
a position of strength and that means he
gets white in game four so while
there's oh my gosh the other game
seconds remaining on the clock and it's
a draw in theory but in practice might
be difficult for
rafa middleton he makes a mistake
apparently
so ralph man of playing black here has
to hold the draw
to save his tournament life
and this is very very tough playing on
increment
he has to just play instantly and yeah
and now e5 this is looking good
yeah
right before me would have been a
problem rook f4
saarinen an excellent endgame player now
rooks hd3 you can't play he played it
but i didn't think you could play this
move e6
is there rook g4 there is that oh whoa
lovely spot
oh and a blunder
huge blunder wait whoa what's the
blunder back
king e4 oh my god
now he's gone
okay he's gonna go back he'll go back
no he goes d6 but now rook g4 forces the
draw
yes and it's a troll okay
yeah h1 we will show that moment once we
look at ralph nominative you pointed out
he's got the shirt in his mouth that is
the nervousness that is on display
online he managed to draw but let's go
to that moment here because it was a
critical one indeed and after rook g4
rook takes g4 was possible because the
king comes back after king f7 we get
this position where it looks like oh
it's just a pawn trade but the king is
locked out on e5 it is not getting to
the corner as we saw the game conclude
so king g6 king g7 h pawn runs white was
winning nihal sarn could have moved on
right here right now
yeah big big chance for nihal gone of
course still in the driving seat only
needs a draw in the final match to go
through the other match ding is tied
with min leap dean has been wobbly as
you like so far
uh but he will
uh still well of course he still has a
great chance with one one round to go
and vladimir kramnik with the clean
sweep of front melchor
means there are only two matches left
for us
to follow
uh i guess we'll go for a short break
robert and then we'll be back
with the action of these final two
matches
who's gonna go through
we'll soon find out don't go anywhere
we'll be right back
so
[Music]
do
open to anyone
all around the world oh my god the
chess.com global championship offers the
dream of playing against the best
and hey have we mentioned there's also a
million dollars at stake the total pot
is a million dollars know that it's not
a typo the prizes are unbelievably
generous
we began with thousands of players
now only dozens remain
he's gonna make it through to the next
phase he secured himself a big place in
the knockouts
the cgc knockout phase has arrived
there are those who played their way in
and some are here thanks to their
well-earned reputations
[Music]
no matter who you are things are about
to get very very real
a trip to the cgc finals and a clean
shot at the largest first place prize of
the year
my friends
it's the cgc round of 64.
who will take the next step to toronto
and we return here in the opening
matches of the chess.com global
championship i'm grand master robert
hess alongside me international master
lawrence trent lawrence vladimir comic
is the first player through to the round
of 32 but we still have two matches to
go here in the first set
yeah a clean sweep for vladimir kramnik
made easy work of fran merkurmian
really didn't even have a sweat in any
of the games
that is quite the opposite of ding
lyring though who has had who's got an
enormous sweat in his game against the
fan favorite minly
uh who
you know won the first game
uh and uh
should have really
won the third game ding liring getting
very lucky to escape with the draw so
that means that match is going tired
into the final well not not necessarily
the final game but the first of the four
games of course if it's tied after that
then we're going to get an armageddon
game and we'll explain that if
we
we get to that point and in the other
match nihal sarin maintaining that a
half point advantage sarin only needs to
make a draw in this final
game and he is through
so
sarin
with the
uh
the advantage of you know even if he
loses this final game he's still got a
shot which is a nice position to be in
but i think we should stay with min lee
against dingle ring because this has
been a a roller coaster affair so far
yeah and you're absolutely right in what
you said about fan favorite minlae he's
tied one half one and a half which is
maybe more than could have been expected
of him at least by rating differential
it certainly is but one thing that
dingley run does to you is he made to
rethink pretty much your entire life the
way he beat min in game two with the
black pieces was a position that looked
unlosable so if you're me you can't just
sort of sit back relax and enjoy a
comfortable looking position every
single move has to be well thought out
because dingley wren is the king at
punishing people from seemingly neutral
positions so right now it's the black
side of rogozin if you're thinking about
from ding's perspective the white king
is far away from castling because you
haven't developed this light square
bishop black on the other hand can
castle right away there's this tension
between the bishop on d7 and the queen
on a4 which makes a knight move possible
for black at some moment knight e4 going
after c3 and that awkward c3 pawn is
going to be something to think about so
i have had more appreciation lawrence
for the regozi in
recent years but i know that a lot of
people they still struggle with it
because if you look at the dynamics of
the bishop hair and more pawns in the
center for white that can be a lot to
deal with
yeah yeah it it can and uh
you know these regards in positions are
you know
they're still
uh very much
on vogue you know their their
fashionable systems
um i didn't really get the hang of them
i tried it a few times from the black
side
um
didn't do particularly well
uh but mindly playing very fast here
looks as though he's in some kind of
prep here
and
i would take white i think black is very
solid but
i think i would still take white ever so
slightly here
yeah i'm with you the bishop pair uh you
know even though white is lacking
development e3 maybe a c4 at some point
the semi-open b file can
apply some pressure along that and maybe
cause black to push upon the b6 and give
up some light squares so i think that
dingley wren i mean he's
super well prepared so i'm not too
concerned from at the moment but i do
see some future promise for min's
position and while they're kind of
ending the opening battle here why don't
we check in the other game because niall
sarin he only needs a draw with the
black pieces and ralph momento he's
playing like mickey adams your
compatriot very quietly nothing special
happening but with the semi-open file
he's just trying to take his little
advantages and make progress from there
yeah uh
you know ralph he's employing
an interesting strategy because
effectively
what
top players have have come to realize is
that
uh you know if you go
to all in so ralph is in a must-win
situation
but actually playing something overly
dubious against the young geniuses just
doesn't work they've analyzed all of
these dubious lines they know when
something is a bluff
and so the only real way to play is to
play something that isn't too
theoretical
and is a little slow and a little
uh
unthreatening let's say
but
one way you maintain chances and you can
build a little bit of pressure and i
really love what ralph has done to do
exactly that but you know siren is
showing that he's up to the top so far i
don't think that his position is bad at
all i guess we're going to see knight
five here though no robert
yeah knight f5 it seems more challenging
than knight takes g6 a lot of people
would take on g6 right away because
after knight g6 pawn takes g6 they would
say oh look at these double pawns but
those aren't bad pawns and now black has
equal control over the open f file
is just going to come very naturally for
black and white has no real way to make
easy progress right this queen can sit
on e7 the bishop can develop in light
squares maybe black can even push this
pawn to g5 so that's why i like your
suggestion lawrence of knight f5 it just
feels like it gives white far more to
play for and to play with
yeah and i haven't to be brutally honest
with you understood what i'm going to do
after bishop takes f5
but i don't think i can be too unhappy
with that move
somehow
at least there's an imbalance of sorts
right like let's say i take with the
rook keep the
line open move my queen out the way
bring my next rook over to f1 even if
there's no concrete
threat it just feels like the pressure
will start mounting and if that's the
case and we keep increasing it then
black is the one was to prove that his
defense is sturdy enough
yeah i think i would also take with the
rook there
just gives you that extra bit of
uh dynamism knight of five is on the
board
okay so now actually it's an important
moment for niall sarin
um
he does go c6 i was thinking about this
move
i'm not overly convinced though by
black's position somehow something is
bothering me bishop b3 i like very much
by ralph improving the bishop was doing
nothing on a4
and
for the first time on a broadcast that
i've been a part of the ambulance is not
from my background that's you
i want to apologize for the
guy who's you know in trouble you know
having a heart attack down the street
for interrupting this broadcast how dare
he
um sorry guys i i live smack bang in the
center of berlin
and
it's it's not exactly you know orange
county we got a lot of
a lot of incidents over here
you know people don't realize that
you're half american so when you make
these uh
you know these references to oc they
don't they don't know that uh
what's rough drink it was a red bull i
thought he was drinking a beer
who's drinking the red bull
uh ralph i just saw him like take a
drink while we were talking there and i
was like wow he's just chilling at home
playing this event you know uh imbibing
a bit having a good old time but i
actually think that he might be a little
bit stressed and he looks it because he
needs to win
and he made them with queen f3 giving up
the bishop trade but in doubling more of
his pawns because the f-file control is
so essential to his chances that he
doesn't really care about pawn structure
so much
yeah um he does look stressed doesn't he
ralph uh ever so
uh ever so slightly he's got a nice
smile but
he's definitely
oh
he he hasn't got the poker face that's
for sure nehal as well looks less
stressed though i will say
uh but calculating now and saying okay
i've got to be a little bit careful for
example here typical mistake that you
could play as a move like queen d7 feels
like you're connecting the ropes
everything's okay but then bam knight
takes h6 or knight takes g7 both are
good i don't know which is even better
but you dropped something and um a full
pawn and effectively the game actually
so
this i i really
you know kudos to ralph
right this is this is a big lesson in
how to play these situations point down
one game to go have to win
just get a position where you can play a
little bit of pressure that's all you
can do at this level
uh
h6 is already a threat so what you've
been pointing out is a hundred percent
true and that's going to cause neal to
think here and what if you move the
knight that would be one of the big
questions if knight takes h6 removing
the guard of this knight is the problem
what if i just move my knight to a
square like h7 it looks awkward but it
avoids your
tactic
yeah exactly and
maybe here white would now go queen g3
is that a move because it's still
difficult to play queen g5 because d6 is
hanging and then i'm threatening bishop
takes e6 straight away knight g5 i can
play h4 so queen g3 might be slightly
problematic and in fact even there
um
what are you supposed to do even with
black there that's not at all apparent
to me there are even some cute little
lines there for example if you go d5
after queen g3
i can take
take
one d5 take now i might even be able to
play bishop d5 bishop d5
uh knight d5 queen e5 queen g6
is uh
possible
i'm just shying off my tactical flare
now robert and you know what after king
h8 i play knight takes g6 first
you'd love to see it come on come on my
gosh and you can repeat because every
good chess player repeats and then you
go back and take the queen but that is
nasty
yeah i i just i i don't want to i don't
want to show off too much because to be
honest i think it will
uh put the fear of god into all my
future opponents
but that's it
no but this is the sort of thing that
could happen this is a very very i like
king h7 though by sarin just giving a
bit more support
to
uh
to these pawns and
now none of the sacrifices seemingly
work
but we got a trade which i definitely
like
we have to applaud ralph's clock
management as well he's a minute and a
half in the lead i mean he has plenty of
time and he's on the defensive he's
bringing his knight to e8 it's
protecting everything g7 d6 the queen
can venture out as you're mentioning
before so i think nihal is doing a great
job at keeping everything together and
what ralph may want is knight g3 to h5
but it's not clear how you really make
the progress necessary to win such a
game so um
he has his work cut out for him and
should we go back over to the game
between
me and let's do it we absolutely should
we absolutely should so
we'll switch games now to dingley wren
versus
midlay it is the
fourth and final well not necessarily
final game but fourth game of the match
and uh oh men in trouble with the white
pieces
yeah slightly worse king is slightly
more exposed
uh and
yeah queen h3 is coming and
this is a sort of if okay if you guess
this robert
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna then mow
you five bucks you ready for this
if i could choose anybody in the world
to play this position with black
who is it that i would choose you've got
one guess
do they have to be living
yes living
who would you choose with the black
pieces to play this position
mama
you know what magnus carlsen said about
jan and various others that he's the
best major peace player in the world
in other words when queens or rooks are
on he believes that jan has got this
this this magic
and i've seen it time and time again
commenting on his games jan napomnishi
is a master in such positions and i
would
i would give jan's position over magnus
just to put things into perspective he's
such a beast
ding of course more than qualified
uh but uh
what
yeah i'm
not quite sure what the right way here
is for black but it feels as though
there's something here
the feel is there but i don't know
quite how
rook d6 feel so it's official and
because where's the rook going where you
still need queen f5 or f6 it takes a
long time to coordinate your pieces in a
way that actually causes problems so
i don't really want to go g5 yeah i know
i'm thinking
i was thinking the same and it's just
such a passer move to go g5 because then
he might just hit you with king h1 or
something and you feel like a pat
it's not ding style either this is much
more ding style okay consolidates on the
queen side
and
that was a surprisingly big moment here
if we just go back a step and analyze
something really quickly this capture on
b5 with the queen rather than the
pawn i think so many my coach taught me
to capture towards the center but look
at the evaluation it is
going south for white because the
problem is this b5 pawn actually helps
black once i play b6 here i can
eventually play c6 in fact and go after
the c3 pawn as well so
this is a situation that you don't want
to capture towards the center you don't
want to help black uh get pawn breaks
and that's why queen takes b5 was
instead played great recognition by min
and after c5 rook b1 rook d6 we're in
this position where both sides are
jockeying uh for control over squares
and to put pressure on pawns
but i like the opportunity for black
against the white king it's looking a
bit lonely
tricky still tricky
um
i think
for
ding he really wanted to
uh
sort of avoid
uh to really mitigate risk in this game
i feel
like he could have chosen many more
aggressive options
against this white weak king and i think
he's just said you know what
i would rather just
not take any risk whatsoever and play in
this style which i don't mind
i think this is a good decision actually
i agree with you because if we look at
this match as a whole what positions has
ding done well in that dry position from
game two with completely symmetrical uh
structure and pieces and he ground men
down so this is the exact type of
position where he would be a favorite
against men knowing that the evaluation
is zeros uh because in game one well he
should have had that game frankly and
then in game three min was outplaying
him tactically so uh we look at this
setup rook to b5 now by min here is
putting more pressure maybe rook to b1
next i think this is anyone's game
despite the fact that there are no minor
pieces nothing
in particular happening at the moment i
really think that either side can take
this one and it's not just in purely
equal position that means it's gonna be
a draw
yeah curious how this one starts to
evolve over the next
few moves has there been any uh major
uh
developments in the
mahmed of sarin game let's quickly have
a look or is it still
calm
not calm at all
i see a rook left so great time to head
over here the evaluation bar says zero's
lawrence but we wait what
um whoa
what
at the very least because rook f1
yeah i mean i understand rook f1 because
he just thinks he's getting all of his
pieces in and
siren in in huge trouble here is he not
he's according to the evil bar of the
side busted already and he doesn't
can we just bring up analysis board and
go over this last move knight f6
seemed totally wrong because
um as we analyze the position like
he went knight back to e8 which was a
good move at the time
and then he brought his pieces of the
defense and here he brings his knight
back to f6
and immediately it just plays into
white's hands d6 is hanging there's all
sorts of knight takes g7 ideas rook g3
at some moment might hurt a lot as well
oh
horrible position
horrible horrible horrible position
you know lawrence i don't think
people will say oh that was a blunder
but and i kind of was on that train at
first but now that i think about it just
great opening choice from mamadou's
point of view he said let me just get
this
position where i have a much clearer
plan my opponent will be on his back
foot this open f file will benefit me
coming up with specific ideas not so
easy for black so i have to give a lot
of credit to the veteran azeri
grandmaster uh this is he's earning this
not just because he
made a
bad move with 906.
yeah totally agree
really really nice to play game and
nihal
starting to understand just how bad
things are here
um
in fact he might have to go knight back
to e8 here
just to
give the queen some some breathing room
but
you can't believe that he'll survive
after knights v8 the
the wide attack just looks
so good what can we do let's see 98
um
let's start with the obvious move rook
g3
queen back to d8
and maybe here
where is the where is the touch where is
the
where is
the i don't
maybe just
i mean i was going to ask though
rook g3 was such a natural move but
maybe also knight g3 to h5
the attack
yes
it's too much
everything is happening i did have
another idea here i just want to show it
because i'm in that kind of mood clearly
that after rook g328
can we play king h1 with the idea knight
g1
knight f3 knight g5 check
how
because knight f6
doesn't really
do very much and i just carry on
knight g1 and i bring the knight in this
way
it's possible i'm not saying it's good
i'm saying it's possible
well it's clearly not bad i mean it
maybe it's not the best move but it's
still saying that white has a plus here
so
that's a clever a very deep idea i would
not have thought about it myself but i
see what you're pointing out that if you
can just kick that king back then you're
gonna have a sack on h6 delivering
checkmate and if black plays f6 ever
they're just weakening your control over
the g files so there is definitely some
merit to it but i mean nihal can't find
a movies on two minutes to nine his
king is
being hunted uh he's just because queen
h5 here
yeah so he's trying to trade queens but
now takes takes knight takes d6 rook d8
i think he wants to then take on d3
um
it's his plan
makes sense
it
feels like this should just there's
gonna be an extra pawn for white in like
five different ways like if you trade
queens d6 f7 b7 all of them are under
attack
yeah it feels like there is something
here for white but a bit of precision is
is required
um
what if he just says queen g3
just keeps the queens on the board then
moves his queen back to f2 and then
brings his rook over and traps this
queen
am i asking for too much
yeah
you're asking for too much robert
[Laughter]
hey come on we're friends you know
friends uh
they let
each other get away with things like
that like making three moves in a row
okay he does go for this yeah and he
does take and he's gonna go knight c3
exactly
no this was a smart and now knight c5 is
coming and he's got lovely control
notice how the pawn on e3 is an
incredibly important pawn
not allowing these knights to get back
into the game we often say double pawns
are bad not here these two double pawns
doing a great job controlling squares
right so ralph with a great great chance
to level up the match for sure but you
mentioned double pawn so i just
brought my eyes to the other game and so
let's go back to that one yeah and it
looks like ralph is going to even this
up we might get tie breaks there but in
this one all of a sudden you know it
looked like a level position but that
rook has leveled up it went from d6 to
f6 to f5 and that's a huge problem
because rook h5 is coming queen f6 was
also a double attack and oh minus three
now all of a sudden after queen to g1
what is the move here
yeah that's that is the question and had
i done my tactics training
a little earlier i might have found it
d4 might be just it
love it
absolutely love it this e3 pawn needs to
stay put otherwise f4 is dropped opening
up the a8 h1 diagonal dingley wren is
feeling this position
and
min
he's down on the clock he's down on the
board he might be down his luck
yeah i think this is just all she wrote
for
for men uh
no redeeming features here
in wyatt's position um
very very tough
queen g3 but
you know now you can even take take on
on e3 it's probably good enough but even
takes takes and
can you just go d3
then c4 i guess okay so
digging decides to keep the queens on
can't be bad either
he's
uh illustrating the point that when you
have the safer king you normally want
more heavy pieces on the board so he
keeps the queen on going after this king
on h1 at some point queen c6 check could
even scoop up a pawn c3 is hanging
oh this is not looking very pleasant for
men his pawn structure is worse and his
king safety is worse
yeah this is uh this is not good at all
uh i really really hate this position
uh well you're in it
you're gonna hate
nihal sauron's position more and you're
gonna hate his time situation nihal
sauron is down to 20 seconds in his game
against ralph while madoff so i think
that his chances of in this particular
game are out the window he's up two to
one so as you said he had that safety
net that cushion where even if he
happened to lose he still gets to go to
a tie break but for the nihal sauron
fans around the globe in particular in
india they're probably biting their
nails nervous that their superstar may
be eliminated here in the opening round
at the chest.com global championship
yeah
a lot of nerves nervy moments here um
but uh
fair play to uh to ralph i mean for for
hanging in there because there's been a
few spots it felt so the match could
have ended a lot earlier we'll stick
here though with mainly takes takes
takes oof
ugly ugly ugly position for for white
no redeeming features worse structure
worse pieces worst king
every single imbalance is in
uh
you know black's favor here
hmm
this is this is not what you want
playing white this is
this is just gross
also it looks like min offered a draw at
some point not now of course but earlier
in the game i'm seeing it in the uh game
chat on chess.com so
apparently min did offer a draw and
dingle wren was not interested and for
good reason
i think
white can almost borderline resign here
yeah it's just over isn't it i mean
objectively it's bad
practically it's bad
weaknesses everywhere
you just can't survive this position
especially against the world number two
um
how do you with one minute against i
mean if let me put it this way
if min saves this game
i have a various hats and i will
happily chew on one on stream
[Laughter]
uh
like you can just take on a4 here there
are no checks even so this is just
yeah and
unfortunately for men he might twirl all
of his hair out by the end but he's not
going to
twirl out of this position he's just his
king is being hunted he's down and
outside past pawn f4 and f2 are doubled
over here
it feels like there should be a win
almost on the spot but it's not that
straightforward
no
still a little bit of work but you tend
to feel like
ding is gonna
find the right way let's go to the other
game because i really think this one is
all she wrote
has
ralph finished
things off here and he's doing very well
but
it's definitely not over
and nihal siren is a tricky customer but
with seven seconds left
you tend to believe that ralph is gonna
find a way
i like b4 and after eight days before a4
give me this past pawn that roams up the
board uh ralph he doesn't need to rush
he can maybe just bring his king up but
oh he takes what was that
what why would you go
why would he do that that's a very
strange decision
now it's very difficult to unravel and
ralph i think realizes it like knight d5
rook b5 okay h3 you just go h5 here
quick i think she's playing for his for
nihal's time trouble and nihal is just
sitting and you were saying it's not
that simple for white to move this
knight and those are double isolated
pawns so
neohal he is a speed demon
he got fortunate there because a4 we
just go back bring up the announcement
very very quickly there it's a good
illustration a picturesque one that it's
not about pawn quantity but equality a4
here was clearly better this pawn go up
the board the king can join the party
sprinting over to the queen side so that
was a huge objective mistake from uh
ralph and look at this the rook is
getting active for knee hall it is a
losing position but this is exactly how
you save positions is that you get some
sort of activity opponents bothered the
good news for ralph is he's up four
minutes
king d3
let's check king c2
f4 okay i mean
trying anything trying something
yeah he wants to take take and maybe go
some
some f3 at some point i'm not sure but
yeah of course it should be losing
uh 96
i rook c7 okay knighted back to e4
so b77
knight b7 knight c5 knight d6 looks
crushing
yeah if you're going
just take that thing this rook needs to
stay on the b file at all costs
yeah this is one
knight a5 can happen
in a moment's notice and
95 95 whichever
yeah you can't take it because then the
pawn promotes
so
ralph he's doing the right thing now i
think he rushed it a little earlier and
he was playing for niels time trouble
now that he
a thousand percent knows he's completely
winning he's just trying to find the
right path and his king he's now about
to walk up
oh but king of four's knight c3 check
knight c3 check okay there's still a
little bit of work here
there's still a little bit of work
before okay
okay six moves oh f3
yes desperate times desperate measures
all that stuff and knight d6
yeah and rook takes t3 that's the round
moment of he evens it up on demand let's
see the oh the other game is over
dingley wren has officially won and
moved on which means we have one game
left and digler didn't just win he
checkmated this king
uh or well he won the queen in the
process so
ding i think that he is going to count
his lucky stars uh we should note that
he's had an exceptionally long day
because he's playing in the chinese
league he had a classical game of chess
today so
we we just need to contextualize but i
think that mainly there's not a extra
monetary prize for a consolation prize
but he deserves a round of applause the
world over he
kept the world number two on his heels
the entire match but dingley red when it
came down to the wire he was able to
win the final game and move on here in
the chess.com global championship
yeah a shaky starting as you said he
played a classical game clearly was
lacking a bit of energy was certainly
playing well below
the level we expect him to play at
unlucky for minli
uh tough first round pairing of course
gets a bit unlucky to get ding in the
first round but that's why this is the
global uh championship we've got some of
the best players in the world playing in
this tournament including ding loren who
will be fighting for the world
championship title uh against
so
uh yeah congratulations to ding of
course lanier kramnik uh already through
he crushed grant mccormian
and uh he goes through and now the
question is is it gonna be sarin or
marmadoff the momentum now
with mahmedof
but are we going to see him follow
through we'll be back in just a few
minutes as we set up the players
for the armageddon playoff we'll go into
detail about how that all works when we
come straight back but don't go anywhere
it's going to be exciting
and we are back here at thechess.com
global championship two matches are done
with dingley wren moves on as does
vladimir kramnik who swept front mokumen
but nihal sauron has not had his way
with ralph mahmedov the match continues
is tied 2-2 and lawrence we get
armageddon where the players are going
to bid on their starting time
precisely and we'll put up a little
graphic here of how it works so
it is an armageddon game meaning there
is one game in one game only
black only needs to make a draw in order
to win but of course
what will happen is black will have less
time
than white that is the way this is
compensated uh the lower bid
plays with the black pieces so both
players are going to suggest a time
they're going to bid a time
and
white will start with 15 minutes
regardless
and so i'm very curious to see what
times they bid at and how quick and good
they think they are from what i've seen
so far
ralph mohmed off has been by far the
quicker player today
and
if i was ralph i would go in for a
global bid around the 12 minute mark
and hopefully
make sure that that's the lowest bid
and if i get that i would be very happy
having draw odds
so i'm very curious what they end up
bidding
if they bid the same amount and what the
times end up being and i believe they're
in the process of doing that straight
away
actually you were a hundred percent
correct with ralph mohammed's bid he did
bid 12 minutes nihal sarin did 11
minutes so nihil gets left wow with the
black pieces ralph gets 15 and white but
if the game is a draw that means that
nihal sarin moves on so if you're
rooting for the indian teenager a draw
is okay he gets through but lawrence
what we just saw from ralph with the
white piece is it's clear he's up to the
task winning on demand with white
wow i'm actually a bit shocked
uh because
well sorry it's ralph who has white it
has to work ralph is white
ralph is white and has to win um
i'm concerned for nihal
i'm concerned for neha
ralph has played
fantastic chess with the white pieces
he's been much quicker
the four-minute differential is huge
it's really a lot
ralph has to play in exactly the same
way you just played
slow game not forcing theory
doesn't matter if he's
equal or slightly better or just has a
game that he can draw out because
ultimately the clock is a big thing here
and i'm very surprised
that nihal went in so low
um i think this is a
uh
a slightly inexperienced bid actually
no i could definitely get behind it
that's the thing when you're bidding it
sometimes 11 minutes that's a lot i
usually play blitz or bullet online but
when you're playing somebody as strong
as in in shape as ralph medal that time
difference is going to hurt you and
there is zero increment so we know that
nihal sauron is like a 3 300 rated
bullet player we know that he made the
70s of the speed chess championship last
year but there's no increment here and
it's a longer time control which means
that if he is faced with this impressive
rook lift and pressure down the f file
like we saw uh a game ago that's not
going to bode well for nihal's chances
so i actually if you know you put made
me put odds on this like i would think
that ralph is suddenly like a 60
favorite
yeah i would i would agree i actually
think ralph is his favorite now
and if you're a nihal sarin fan and many
people watching this are going to be big
nihal siren fans i would have
every right to be slightly nervous of
course nihal is more than capable of of
pulling it off but
i don't know
the momentum is in ralph's favor
the experience on ralph's side wouldn't
surprise me at all to see the azeri
grand master come through
ralph head in hands already thinking
about what opening he's going to play
how he's going to set out nihal
not yet at his desk
remember they're playing for a huge
amount of money in this global
championships
uh 200 thousand dollars first prize
uh it is a groundbreaking
prize fund for this kind of tournament
one million total
uh prize fund
quite extraordinary and uh well we're
gonna soon see which of these players
goes through to chase that dream of
winning the big cash and we have our
first
mini
surprise
do you remember what this one's called
robert
yes because i played it as a child it's
the wormhold attack yes i played this
actually quite a lot and it's a slower
approach which can be seen as well
you're not really getting much of an
opening edge but it's nice when you have
a lead on the clock from the very first
sort of look nihal is the first person
to start digging deep trying to come up
with a plan he's playing much in the
same vein as he did in the previous game
but ralph just feels comfortable here
that's the thing is even if the eval bar
is saying there's nothing going on
there's a lot beneath the surface
there really is yeah
um
but i think this is again a pretty
decent choice
by ralph just to get a position he
doesn't really
care about being better or
you know pressurizing nihal he just
needs to get a position where he can
play a long game he's trying to take
advantage leverage the fact that he's
got four extra minutes on the clock
nihal understands he's got to play
quicker and wow there we get the first
mini surprise
by ralph he goes for an early g4
this i am slightly surprised by it's
probably all right he wants to put the
knight on g3 and put the knight on f5
um
so i don't hate it in that sense but i
am surprised
you you know
what this uh why this move can be played
is because black has this pawn on b5
which is part of the opening from the
black side of a spanish but it means
that black's king can't really castle
side and that means that castling
kingside is where it's going to go and
then you have a g5 quickly hitting black
where it hurts so the pawn on h6 is a
bit of a hook here and that is why
mammoth can play in this vein
yeah absolutely and i you know the more
i look at it the more i actually quite
like it because you also
make nihal pause and think for a little
while
um and it's not too outrageous
uh to play g4 knight g3 it's not some
you know it's not uh
um
too risky
we see it in a lot in these structures
reminds me of the famous game
caba blanca marshall
cava blanca marshall
i can't quite remember the year
where kappa blanca managed to get a big
knight on f5
um
and marshall's bishop was
was was on h5 in that position but still
the point remains the knight is
beautiful on f5
and yeah i like white's position
yeah the only thing i'm worried about
from ralph's perspective is if he's
going to bite a hole in his shirt
because he's been nibbling away this
whole game he's clearly
nervous he cares a lot about the results
here but white is just significantly
better
practically speaking white is better you
have more space thanks to these advanced
pawns over here the knight on f5 is just
such a nuisance you can never play g6
because you'll drop this h6 pawn and
you're well ahead in the clock because
you started with a four minute lead that
now has grown into four and a half uh
minutes so um ralph he has a chance here
he can take on b6 lawrence i'm not sure
i would do that i know it doubles the
pawns and makes d6 a little bit loose
but leaving the tension here also makes
sense because black doesn't especially
want to take on e3 to allow white to
take with the f-pawn
yeah i don't see bishop 6b 6 happening
anytime soon actually um
hmm you seem that's it i don't have so
many easy moves here is white
you could cast a queen side but i don't
think he wants to do that very soon so
he does do it okay
and now maybe queen c7 just a simple
move to defend the b6 pawn keep d6
defended as well
later in the game once you defend
everything you could even consider queen
c5
so i still prefer i mean i'm going to
say this all game white is going to be
the side for choice
but nihal maybe he can play the next few
moves quickly although after d4 you
certainly aren't going to rush
yeah
no i think ralph uh in the driving seat
clearly here
and nihal is gonna have to
come up with something quick
or
face uh
real adversity
i hate his position lawrence i really
really don't like this for neil
i get it i get it
it's
uh it's hard to find a move white has
got
the space advantage everywhere
brilliant
opening choice
by ralph mahmoud
and
you from the very beginning you were
talking about how uh ralph has this
experience and people of course are
talking about nihal who's a fantastic
player one of the best players in the
world but i think people don't quite
understand what experience means and uh
you know they know oh he's played more
games he's played longer great but they
don't understand that in moments like
this in situations when you're bidding a
certain amount of time when you're
choosing an opening in a must-win game
ralph knows how to handle these pressure
situations because he's been there
before and it's not a knock on nihal
it's just he's very young and hasn't
played that much chess at least not as
much high-stakes chess so
i think that ralph was doing everything
you could ask him nihal stills hanging
in this game and also the
the lead on the clock is shrinking all
of a sudden uh it was it ballooned up to
five plus minutes now it's back down to
four minutes seven minutes 41 seconds is
an eternity for a player like nihal
sarin so i do think that while i like
white's position and maybe e takes f5
can be played to open up the e file and
pin this pawn uh that does allow this
knight eventually to hop into m4 so it's
still a complex battle
yeah super complex so i i do feel as
though
saren would have been happy with
um
the past few moves somehow i get that
impression remember sarin only needs to
make a draw here with black
uh he's managed to get some kind
of uh
stability but at the same time he can't
ever cast a queen side because a6 is
hanging so
i'm not sure
so yeah exactly so ralph does castle and
i think
he really wants to play something like
king g2f3 here
just to
break open the position and and then
start landing on some of these weak
squares
good call and it's just a tough moment
here for nihal because he can't castle
king side he already moved his roof
right
if you push the g pawn h6 will fall you
don't want to give that pawn away and if
you do
nothing so to speak there could be a c4
there's a pawn break that removes the d5
pawn which is defending e4 as you point
out f3 at any moment is going to be an
issue you can play b4 rook a3 rook a1
just increase the pressure on the queen
side so i feel like black needs to be
quick
and i meant that over the board but i'm
looking at the clock once again now down
to six minutes 45 seconds in a
very complicated position here
i think nihal is considering king d7
yeah i think that's a tough move to play
though because
ah
you know you've got visions of this
knight landing on e5 would check in some
positions
that said i'm
i am struggling here for black
yeah with a big exhalation there
big big exhale
normally a sign off
you know
he understands that this is
really tough ralph looking much more
relaxed
right and without the increment this is
getting very worrying for nihal sarin
because let's say he gets down to one
minute left he can't build up time and
so nihal is fully concentrated but what
ralph has done so well it's the hikaru
nakamura school of speeches is
oftentimes it's better to play a good
move quickly than the best move slowly
and nihal he needs to be careful just
because of the precarious nature of his
position
but you gotta move now you're down to
five and a half minutes you've half the
time of your opponent you're worse on
the board and your king is never going
to find true shelter
yeah and this is precisely why i think
an 11 minute bid by nihal was
uh absolutely uh ridiculous actually um
he was already a much slower player he
should have noticed in the first four
games
and he should have probably bid
something like 13 minutes which had a
really good chance of being the wrong
bid and if it was the right bit he gets
an extra two minutes and if it's the
wrong bit okay he has to win with white
um
but
is more than capable too and now he's in
a spot under five minutes
no easy move on the board
um
you know just
the time just starts ticking and ticking
and then you
now he's the nerves and the anxiety is
kicking in and he does finally go
for for king f8 but this is meant by
c4
it takes it wow okay
knight takes e4 is possible here rookie
8 there's always queen a3 check
so that check is very important here to
get out of the pin
yeah this is
actually just nasty for black
knight takes e4 is just a move you you
really should be playing here i feel
um but
ralph's considering something there's
something he doesn't like
well i mean
he's got other moves in this position
uh
you know he might want to play a move
like rook fc one for example b5 b3
makes
uh
a whole ton of sense trying to
win this c pawn
um
anybody eventually does to settle for
knight takes e4
and
nihal of course sees that queen a3 check
is in the air
and
this is a really tough position
i wonder if you should go queen e7 here
as nihal sorry
because at least
at least there's no queen a3 check and
if i can trade some pieces
how bad can it be
still bad probably but
i can't find that though
it's hard
this this is not this is not easy
at all
for sarin
yeah i mean knight d5 is also possible
but
more than the position i'm getting so
concerned about his time he's not a
three minutes 40 seconds
no increment
yeah this is this is just uh
a catastrophic spot for nihal now he's
just getting flustered
three minutes
ralph has got ten
minutes seven minute gap now's gonna
have to play at breakneck speed
the move isn't obvious
decides to take but this is you know a
really depressing decision now you don't
even know what you're supposed to do
with this rook because yeah okay you can
play rookie queen of three exactly now
what'd you do about this a pawn he goes
a5 and
yeah all of these moves that ralph is
playing are just good moves
trying to trade off here you can't get
this rook from g8 into the game because
you try and keep a rook on rook d8
now you've got many moves for
uh for white
um rookie four i was just about to say
that exactly
for now you double
then you can play queen a3 queen e3
whatever you want
all kinds of stuff you have some f6s
it's just
it's just horrible
houses only plus 1.4 it looks like
plus it looks dead doesn't it yeah it
really does
wow
drastic drastic measures but now you
just go f6 is right you don't think f6
there could be rook g6 and
i'm not saying that black is okay but
maybe there's a way to slither that king
at some point the g8 and h7 it looks
really bad
obviously it looks too like f6 rook g6
rook ae1 if king g8 i go rookie a check
and
uh
there's something here maybe queen d
six or something
just go for this pawn
that's the problem with pushing pawns
queen d6
yeah that is a problem isn't it
and it's incredibly tempting to play f6
to keep this king locked in you see that
king g7 is the desired goal is queen d6
first which apparently is a big mistake
a huge mistake
looks like such a no
oh we both saw it like the same time
wow and the point is after it takes
takes it's not because queen f4 e7 is
not clear
queen f4 here that's the move
yeah this is
king g7 i take on d8
and then queen b7 check
oh
you continue your attack but to see this
not just to see this from a mile away
but to assess it accurately is really
really difficult so queen d6 from queen
c3 instead and we've been talking about
this it may not be the best move it may
not be the perfect move but it's good
enough and played quickly so nihal
backed on the clock two minutes and 12
seconds remaining for the indian
teenager the superstar
and now he's down a pawn but if he could
trade queens he has huge chances to hold
yeah i i feel like he's uh the position
is definitely improved now
this was an excellent decision but
he still has the time issue this is the
problem
he still has only two minutes to hold
this position so he's gonna have to be
very very efficient with the mouse
um
yeah this is still
very very tough
that game that ralph won
in game four we were talking about the
decision b4 and a takes b4 he
wasn't playing
super accurately down the stretch and
right now his accuracy has been tailing
off a bit and nihal with two minutes is
like most players with six the guy is so
fast calculated so well we see ralph
biting his shirt again he undoubtedly is
nervous he knows neil he's played him
many times online he knows his
reputation and he's certainly worried
that wait a second hasn't black just
completely stabilized
yeah i mean
black is a pawn down
that should be pointed out
i wonder if he
does queen e5 check make sense that's my
question
probably with the idea
yeah
so yeah so he plays another passing move
rookie three queen f6
wow
so yeah
[Music]
you mentioned sorry uh lawrence you
mentioned the whites of a pawn but it's
almost like
whites up a palm up blacks also a pawn
because blacks up a queen side pawn
whereas white has an actual d4 and f5 so
that imbalance
helps black's chances and with a rook c1
and a rook d6 and rook d1 all sorts of
plans here to go after white's hanging
pawns
totally agree yeah i mean
as i said i think black has done
extraordinarily well to get to this
position
if i'm ralph i really want to keep a
two-minute cushion against nihal i do i
want to keep the two minutes and i've
got moves to do that like for example
okay queen e5
like i think it's a mistake
yeah
rook c4 makes a lot of sense this move i
like by ralph really nice move oh sorry
by uh nihal
yeah ralph
looking at this saying how did i get to
this position after such a glorious
moment earlier
must be very annoying
i take it back everybody always play the
best move don't play good moves quickly
you always play the best move because
when you're playing against nihal sarin
if you don't play with pinpoint
precision he is going to counter and
i'm going to go out on a limb here and
say that i believe the chances are
greater than 50 that nihal holds this
game
wow okay
so you're giving me evens on ralph
coming through
yes
that's better than these nfl spreads
buddy
but i mean we look at the position here
pieces are coming at the board if you
take with this rook there's a rook b7
following rook e to e7 and f7 will fall
that's why i took with this rook you can
go rook before rook f8 okay lawrence
there's i i don't think ralph's winning
this game rook of fate
all right i'll take the ralph overall
victory for for uh for five bucks
okay
you know not that i promote gambling but
we're not promoting this it's just a bit
of fun
between two friends
oh and the advantage now turning in
nehal's favor why is that
oh because you can bring rook c8 and
check and you can't leave this second
rank for this e2 rook
okay but that's tricky
so it's called rook c8 probably a rook d
same idea
okay king f2
or king g2
ah he wants rook dd3 next that's
annoying
and then the black king can actually
walk into f4 like
just checkmate white at the end of this
all right i'm nervous
i'm nervous
well ralph is nervous too
wow
okay
he's nervous he's hungry and nihal all
of a sudden
he looks ready to secure his spot in the
round of 32.
yeah but he's only got a minute and now
ralph needs to now now he needs to to
use every part of his
imagination and genius
but it looks very very tough suddenly i
have to say
um
what are you supposed to even you know
what
you know what i'm going to do i play
rookie e7 exactly rugby 2 king g3 rook
faye and rook e c7
this is what i do here king g3
and rookie c7 correct well done ralph
this is the
oh but yeah rook a7 this might be a
brilliant move because yeah b5 and then
rook c5
not check because
okay
okay this is not going to be
he's moving too slowly though 53 seconds
yeah this is what i'm saying it's going
to be a nail-biting finish brookie
he's the
best bullet player on the planet but
he's found four does he know he doesn't
have increment
i think he knows
i feel like
no he's like too slowly to know
what is happening
b5
rook d5
why is he moving so slowly
you got to hurry up rugby too
king g7 will be played
okay now
now you've got a uh
king g8
goodness me
oh you know what he's sweating up with a
punnet
but with the pawn on g5 if this rook
gets there he's gonna checkmate him
oh my god he set this up
no it's checkmate
oh my goodness
oh my god
he set it up
he lulled him into a trance thinking oh
my gosh i'm just going to easily win he
set this up brilliantly with the pawn on
g5
rook c2
you got to go you've 16 second oh my
gosh that's working one is good enough
it's the same thing
and you just make a draw right a draw is
a win
oh it's mate
oh my gosh wait is he going to be in
time 15 seconds
just what great decision making by ralph
trick him try to confuse him
oh my gosh 12 seconds you gotta oh you
got to go nihon
oh he's gonna be through b2b1 he can
almost like pre-move it
b3 oh great
neil's so fast
the speed
f2
oh you know what you should do repeat
moves okay but f1 queen is pre-movable
and if you get the last piece off the
board you can't lose
and it's going to be made
oh mate
my goodness
nihal sarin
is a magician
and he wrecked him ralph he eliminates
the azeri grandmaster what a brilliant
display of pattern recognition from
nihalsar we gotta go back in time here
because
it looked like it was over that ralph
momento you're doing everything right
around here
the problem for nihal was on the clock
he was down to
21 seconds
but a brilliant
setup by nihal rook b7 taking his eyes
off his own king while trying to stop
these pawns and then rook c8 with the
rook coming down to either c2 or c1 the
pawn on g5 takes away the escape squares
this is unbelievable stuff from the
indian sensation
i mean
could we have asked for more from a
first round of matches
uh what a battle these guys had
nihal sarin just
too
quick by a few seconds
showing off how good he is at bullet
four seconds left he had on his clock to
finish that one off a valiant effort by
ralph
uh but
it is the young indian superstar who
manages to go through
bad news is i know robin
i owe robert himself
good news is you my
my bracket is still still alive
i just can't get over how good a bullet
he is i didn't even think about this f
pawn honestly i was looking how do i
push these pawns over here but like the
full board awareness it seems obvious
when you have all the time in the world
to analyze but i'm looking as oh does b3
work and it does in fact win the game of
course but look at how long this takes
right now you have to all right you'll
win this pawn to make a draw but like
takes so much longer to figure this
stuff out so nihal sarin i mean the guy
is just an absolute
whiz kid he moves on to the next round
barely but i think this is good for him
like
i have nihal in my top eight and i think
having a close match like this where
he'll learn more about bidding and how
much time he can really have when he um
is without increment i think these kind
of things benefit a young player just
getting this experience in
yeah and i think he'll use this robert
as we were saying i guess he's going to
even watch the stream back
and probably work out that his his bid
was actually he lobeled way too hard if
he if he has another armageddon shot
he's not really a guy
stylistically because he takes those
long uh things who should be
uh bidding 11 in the future and i think
he'll he'll change that
um
let's just have a quick
uh sort of summary again for people well
if you've just joined us
you've missed an unbelievable day of
chess uh so far and we've got plenty
more action to come this is just the
first round there will be more
uh from the global chess championships
shortly after we've done we're finished
here but
quick summary ding lyrin
has managed to beat
uh min lee after a topsy-turvy affair
where
min lee certainly had his chances to
cause a major upset in the first round
but it was dingler in with a bit more
clutch play it towards the end who
managed to
do the job vladimir kramnik no sweat at
all white washes mel kumian kramnik
looked absolutely sublime uh
you know talk of him being old retired
can't play online and the rest of it
uh i think has been um soundly refuted
today by his play
i think he's taking this tournament very
very seriously and i expect a deep run
by vladimir kramnik and as we've just
seen nihal sarin
beating mahmed off in the armageddon
match
and absolutely
uh
just
dramatic
heart thumping finish
and it means that the young indian
grandmaster superstar beats his
a re opponent
and
um
the three in my opinion
rating favorites even though ralph
mahmed off theoretically was higher
rated than sarin if we look at um
classical ratings as well and and maybe
some other metrics sorry probably the
favorite on paper
but uh all the favorites do go through
uh so uh so far
um
any for any final thoughts
yourself there robert
i certainly do about this side of the
bracket that four-five match-up between
andre yessipanko and bassem amin
yesapanko he is world famous
for beating magnus carlsen in the tata
steel masters a few years back but
basemame the best player from the
african continent the egyptian legend is
also a doctor a medical doctor and you
know he's been over twenty seven hundred
he can really hang with the best of them
and if ralph mametov gave us any
indication as did
min lay at the top of the bracket there
there's no easy points here not a single
one
i mean these players are superstars and
that's how strong the global
championship is the lowest rated player
in the entire field is still over 2500
in classical chess and feeding and
better than that in the rapid time
control so i know that you have
yesipanko going far as the four seed
think about that andre yesipanko is the
fourth highest seed in this side of the
bracket that's crazy to think about and
we just had a whirlwind of an opening
series of matches lawrence i mean that
was
just the most fun that i could have
asked for when i wake up before 6 a.m
here in new york
yeah uh and a big shout out of course to
everybody who did join us from the us
who got up super early
uh or people who who made an effort to
come and watch this the action is not
over today two things to uh tell you
guys about firstly there is the gordon
hayward arena go to
go.chess.com forward slash play gordon
to join uh you can play against him but
if you want to watch the next round of
matches from the global
challenge
uh you can see
those in around 90 minutes
time
and it will be
uh
well well the matches are look
absolutely fantastic we've got yesipinko
i mean from this group that we've just
commentated on vallejo ponz the spanish
number one against the russian
grandmaster matlikov how about battle of
the two young grand masters sevian and
the very solid germans fan uh playing
against sevilla
we've got liam la cuan
who of course well known out of st louis
now playing against one half of the
chess bra
eric hansen who qualified early doors
to this stage of the competition that's
going to be a real fun one as is
alexianco against mr martinez aka jospem
more commonly known if you watch the
chess.com streams a very very talented
rap player alexeyenko of course having
qualified for the candidates couple
years back
very very uh you know decent player in
his in his own right of course
tons of great matches and those will be
commentated by
the one and only daniel naradiski aka
dania
and well it looks as though the big man
has decided to step into the booth
himself
the one and only
chess.coms
chief chess officer danny wrench
taking a time out from
what does he do nowadays robert like a
bit of crossfit
daddy up daddy roll daddy um
tasks
does he actually play chess anymore
what's his steal he's gonna be there you
know that should be very surprising
he does play a bit of chess and of
course he uh covers all the chess around
the globe he's you know got his hand in
many different uh cookie jars but he
will have to call with dania and that
will be very exciting stuff after the
gordon hayward
arena of course but i do want to give a
quick shout out to my good friend daryl
mori we're in in the nba he's the
president of basketball operations for
the philadelphia 76ers it is his 50th
birthday he's a huge chess fan uh he
loves loves loves the game and so happy
birthday to daryl but for now lawrence
and i are going to say goodbye please
have a great rest of your day it's only
just getting started especially if
you're in the united states gordon
haywards arena comes up next then it's
more from the chess.com global
championship you'll not want to miss any
of the action
no stranger to making a good first
impression andre yasipenko had his hello
world moment at the turn of last year
competing at the prestigious tata steel
tournament yasipanko managed a shocking
victory over the reigning world champion
magnus carlson
it is just groundbreaking one of the
only players who have a winning record
against magnus carlsen
only 18 at the time yasipanko made
history as the youngest player to hand
carlson a defeat in a classical game
during his world championship reign
18 year old andrei yasipanko just beat
the world champion in a classical game
wow
in late summer the teen sensation had
saved plenty of mojo for competing in
one of the final opportunities to
qualify for the cgc
oh man he's got quite the mouse
that's
showing the gears on his bike there
dominating his play in session yasipanko
won six of his nine games including
three draws to take first place and
punch his ticket to the round of 64.
andrea cepenko has qualified another
super jam claims a spot in the 64 player
knockout
despite his age and lack of experience
compared to other veterans in his group
yasipanko has every reason to believe he
can earn a seat at the table in toronto
this november
[Music]
so
do
[Music]
um